[Music]
and we are
live welcome back guys to the uh
i am not a gm tournament and can also
say welcome back
to grand master robert hess who's going
to be joining me again for the
commentary welcome buddy
hey i appreciate it i'm glad to be back
i should have worn a suit again so
people would be confused
which event we're covering today yeah i
i noticed that you look a lot more fancy
and
formal when you're commentating the tata
but you know we got our dress down
uh sweaters and t-shirts for i am not a
g
it's how you know i'm being at my most
serious is when i'm dressed down
that's when i'm sharpest so just so you
know everybody that this is what i take
seriously i love
this event in a month i had a great time
watching you and james commentate
yesterday
yeah it was a lot of fun and that was
just one of the matches
uh very enjoyable to commentate but they
really all have been let's remind people
of the format for this event of course
we have the
the main bracket single elimination so
you know you lose you go home
there's gonna be five plus one blitz
three plus one blitz
and 25 minutes of one plus one bullet
chest so you get all
time controls all formats for this and
of course the winner
advances to the next round which we've
seen so far and they're advancing to the
next round and competing for
even more money robert i mean it's not
too shabby ten thousand dollar
total prize fund um you know as an i
am i would say that's that's not too bad
to be competing for
oh of course not they also love it you
know they have so much fun even when
they're as nervous as teddy coleman was
yesterday
they enjoyed the experience of getting
to play some serious competition
that is in just the spirit of having
some good chess and a good time
yeah absolutely so more more money at
stake the more points
you collect and here is the bracket we
we
saw that match that robert was just
mentioning yesterday uh
teddy coleman did come with the victory
against carissa yet
um today we're going to be getting into
the match uh kostya kavitsky you can see
in
sort of the top left of the screen there
against tanya saktev
and that is going to be the focus for
today
robert this uh this match is certainly
going to be an exciting one
um but i feel like i don't even need to
say that anymore with the you know
that's just what we expect
from this tournament um kostya and tanya
what
would you have uh what do you have in
store for us you know
it's funny we as you said we don't just
speak into the existence and
speaking of speaking tanya she's a very
popular commentator
of course she's a very strong player in
her own right and kosia
he teaches very often i know he's on
twitch with david pruis and they uh
very instructive lessons that they're
often given
well late into the night because they're
on the west coast so i don't know who's
the favorite this is the eight
nine match up and i would probably go
with costia i think he's just more
experienced online particularly in
bullet but
i would not be surprised at all if tanya
takes this match
right yeah that i think you mentioned
something which uh we could see being
very pivotal
um you and i were talking pre-show and
you had informed me that tanya
actually did not have a good go in the
bullet section now
hey could have been because she was
playing levy rosman in the last edition
of this tournament but it could also be
because
bullet chess is something that generally
favors someone who's playing online more
a lot more active in that uh you know
with the mouse and
um i think that that's got to be kasich
kavitsky in this match so
the bullet portion is something that i'm
really going to be looking out for but
i expect him to go toe-to-toe for sure
in the blitz at least
yeah and it goes to himself he did get
out to a slow start when he played last
year
he'll look to score better in the early
stages because that can be deflating
many players myself included if you lose
one game two game
you feel like you're just never going to
get that victory when are you gonna
right the ship
and there isn't that much time in this
format especially psychologically
yeah yeah i know it's it's important to
note that the uh
the times for each format of course that
the bullet has the least amount of time
only 25 minutes but
it can make such a big impact because of
how quick those games go
um what i've noticed from this format is
you and i commentate a couple five
minute games and
it's like halfway done already it's like
whoa time flies
yes and those breaks can come at
inopportune moments for certain players
they go on
a little bit of a winning streak and
there's a break so that the players can
go study the opening line and fix their
mistakes and that is a very important
storyline as well
yeah yeah the the being adaptive i think
is really important
in these matches and i don't know if
it's something that's true or not but
i feel like the more adaptive player or
the less stubborn player
tends to do really well in these matches
i wonder if i could get a stat on that
to back it up but
i feel like that's the case yeah and
karissa
i think she played better overall than
teddy i think he would admit that as
well
and she was switching her openings up
but that
i would agree with you by and large
you'll see that the players who are able
to play c4 or play
d4 e4 they can switch it up it causes
confusion for players
what are you expecting from me and well
the games are off and we have
a qgd right now quiet line to start with
these players i feel like both of them
they go for very principled chess
and less so for speculative sacrifices
definitely i was going to say something
very similar as soon as i saw this
opening
it almost jogged my memory oh yeah
that's right these guys played very very
principal chess a lot of main lines
i don't know about the the theory being
so in depth but what i would guess is
that costia
is definitely going to be on top of
things that sort of happens when you're
in that coaching mentality you sort of
have to be up to date
on the latest and greatest in in theory
in a bunch of random different openings
because
you're not just studying and preparing
for yourself anymore you might have
a bunch of different students that play
all sorts of different openings so you
get that general sense of preparation
yeah and that's really important and
tanya does a lot of commentary and
as someone who does such you don't
really study at least not for your
uh shows and for your work you're not
studying the openings so deeply you see
them very often
and then in some to some extent you
could be like well the top player is
doing this
this is good right like if i see levon
aronian do something i'm like well
that's probably
a good decision but it doesn't get you
to the fundamental understanding of why
things are happening and here
tanya's spending her time after c takes
d5 she's probably considering
do i take knight takes d5 or throw in
the c takes d4 move which she has done
and when i look at this position i'm on
that king on e1 can i somehow just pin
this knight
with a quick queen a5 bishop b4 or do i
have to spend the time reacting to this
pawn on d5
well uh now that i see queen takes d4
i'm less
i feel less confident in the bishop
before stuff but
um i think i could just play e takes d
i'd be a little more tempted by ed5
um just to get knight c6 with tempo
after seeing queen d4 but
um knight takes d5 and the reason i
wasn't liking this was i thought
knight takes and bishop b2 was like kind
of kind of just a nice
quick way to get all the pieces to where
exactly where you want them
right and if all the pieces start
getting traded off here where let's say
you know knight takes d5 e takes d5 for
black the idea is bishop f6
winning that rook on the corner as you
point out bishop b2 it forces black's
hand to play bishop f6 but these trades
tend to help white and the reason why is
when even isolated pawn which the pawn
d5 is you want to blockade that pawn so
at the end of all of this
white would like a knight or a rook to
land on the d4 square
and that pawn on d5 is a permanent
target
yeah and uh i would say it just feels
like a very very
small edge to to costia here but
not definitely not a big deal i mean
there there's so many
you know theoretical positions where you
have that isolated pawn and
you just get the knight to bring the
bishop to f5 to e4
and just sort of sit there attacking the
knight putting pressure on g2
and you know tanya is not going to be
too upset with this but
um vice versa i'd say koci has got to be
satisfied with
what looks like a comfortable edge to
start off this match and just one of
these positions where you feel like you
have no risk
from the white side your position is
better your opponent has the worst pawn
structure
you can quickly castle king side in the
next few moves so
i would kind of dream of having these
type of position especially in a blitz
game i think white's moves are very easy
to make
and we already see in a minute advantage
in the clock for costia
yeah bishop g4 so again
you could always throw in just bishop e2
nice and simple getting castled um that
would be my
my thought without um looking into the
position too much if you
wanted to to maybe calculate something
else like bishop takes and play knight
d4 it would be my other suggestion but i
think this
is just simple solid and you know get
the king out of the middle bring the
rooks to
c and d files and this looks like a very
comfortable
easy play for white and i don't think
tanya
is comfortable at all from the black
side she's really burning some clock
here
it's an extra minute and you know if it
keeps staying at this pace
she'll have very little time to figure
out the nuances and
you need to play d4 at some point for
black that's what you're like
want to do you don't want to passively
defend can i push this pawn to d4
but the big problem is well first b4 i
just okay
cozy goes to trade queens but i think
even b4 there to keep the queens on
could have been good but uh it's very
difficult for black to
get this move to work and you can just
take back on d2
with the king put a rook on d1 put a
work on c1
and it's going to be a really uphill
battle
for tonya to try to hold this position
yeah and the annoying thing is like
after king takes d2 knight c6
if even if you play bishop takes f3 and
d4
and it somehow works white can't always
play something like e4
and it's it's never clear if that pawn
on d4
is actually a good pawn or not you know
it's a pass spawn but could also just be
overextended so
i think costia like he's doing exactly
what you want to do in
a match like this you get an easy
position
you don't have to worry about the clock
um and i think he's just gonna test this
style for game one and see where it gets
them absolutely and the king of the
center that's a good thing we're in an
end game
the king on d2 will slide back to e1 to
make the rook look
better on the d file but the point is
that the king is happy to be in the
center
you have great lines for rook d1 and c1
and actually taking to mind what you
were saying where if black plays d4
white can just play pawn e4 maybe you
don't even need to move your king just
yet
and so perhaps costia will do something
else and actually knight d4
could be a nice tactical move in this
position because efficient e2 king e2
and you're ready to blockade and attack
this d5 bomb
yeah knight d4 looks like a nice way to
start
um also even if h3 bishop takes
f3 happens followed by d4 i mean even
something like bishop takes c6
and that slight slight imbalance of
having that pawn there in a rook end
game
like sometimes that alone can be enough
coupled with the fact that that king
is so much more active than the black
king and it's it's getting towards an
end game
right and i think you're right just
bishop takes c6 here and yeah i actually
think that
black is in big trouble it's even
material but the quality of the pieces
certainly favors white and it's because
of this king
it's going to be very active it's
centralized and
you would like to go and attack these
queen side pawns so bishop takes c6
would be my move i
probably and there it goes and does
black
already have to start thinking well am i
going to go down a pawn in a rook end
game and try to hold that because i'm
not sure
you keep both queenside pawns
considering their split
right uh i guess i would probably take
as opposed to letting
the king decide to go to c3 or e3 after
taking
on uh um taking on c6 and white takes on
on here on d4
decides to take yeah this is just this
is just uncomfortable with a minute left
uh i mean this might be even if rolls
were reversed and white had a minute
i'd probably still take white but but
this is just not not good enough i think
in in this format no look at this right
since the a7
c6 split that and i keep focusing on and
look rook c4
white's king is on e3 black's king is on
g it's she'll have to spend time with
king f8 king e7 but rook a4 forces the
rook back to d7
then you go rook a6 and then the rook
has to protect both pawns and you play
rook
c7 that allows the white king to go
directly into d4
and then c5 and because white's king was
in the center he's quicker to the action
yeah and there might be a zuk's one if
tanya plays t passively rook c7 and king
d7
holds c6 and holds a7 but that is the
only position that holds c6 and holds a7
so as soon as as the the turn passes
over to costa i think
i think tanya might be in serious
trouble so
yeah this this is not not good at all
when you're playing passive in a rook
end game robert that's like
the cardinal rule you know that
something's gone wrong yeah this is
actually
very instructive technique from kostya i
think everything he's done has had
purpose
and it's not like tanya's blundered
she's made no serious mistakes
but this is how chess often is at this
high level is you get a position that's
uncomfortable
you need to find every last accurate
move otherwise
you get here and as you said one this is
going to be a soup swamp in fact
if black has no more pawn moves and
you're running out of them and you're
also running out of time
but if you have no more pawn moves you
need to move your rook or your king and
your
rope takes a7 check and that's one pawn
the rest will also fall in the near
future
yeah there's nothing to do you just put
that rook back on a6 and it's like well
hey nothing's changed now i just played
b4 a4 a5
put the rook on b6 like um nothing has
has changed about uh
about this pawn now you could play rook
takes c6 but i think rook a7 is d
stronger move and king e6 blocks your
own rook
so you can't even get active um just
really really
impressive technique from kosia in game
one
and tanya's gonna have to revisit that
whole
i guess that whole energy that she came
with that game she's gotta play
faster and she can't simplify into these
slightly worse positions
um while going down on the clock that
might have been a perfect game from
costa
i don't think he made a single
inaccurate move there maybe
something slight perhaps h3 wasn't as
you know precisely some other move but
from our perspective on that was as
perfect as it gets
like a 99 plus percent game yeah
and it's like wow okay so i think maybe
tiny i just need to play a different
opening and
of course she doesn't but that's the
thought i get when
you're in a blitz match where the next
game starts immediately it's as if
your whole repertoire is wrong because
that isolated pawn is something that
kosio is delighted to see
wow we have a sharp game already with h5
by costa this is how you play against
the knight on g3
in these same-ish lines in the king's
indian but among what do you know about
this because it feels very risky as well
yeah uh the the thing is i i think it's
accentuated
in in classical chess so in blitz i
still think it's a very reasonable
option
um even h4 here uh to bring the knight
back yeah and that's that's what he's
gonna do
um you could at some point put this pawn
down to h3
and the idea is you're sort of
committing to potentially losing that
that pawn in a lot of lines but it's
it's it's the decoy it's it's there that
if white wants to go like bishop g5
bishop takes h4 or if white wants to go
you know h3 g3 and then knight g1 and
bishop takes h3
just to win that pawn so many pieces are
going to be taken out of the center and
that's like one
two three moves that you hand over to
black so i think that's exactly what
khasi is going for he's looking to make
the investment of the pawn worth it by
by moves on the board yeah he sacrificed
the pawn on the queen side where
tiny could have taken on b5 i like her
decision just to blick queen to d2
and now the queen side will be a bit
locked up and that bishop on g7 is often
very powerful
in these sharper kings indian lines at
some point in the near future she could
just play bishop h6 trade off
what is going to be black's best hope of
an act of peace
and i think that will definitely be in
her favor so right now
she has a choice do i keep the position
locked up or do i play with the a3 that
comes to mind as well
if your opponent's pawns stick out like
a sore thumb all the way there in b4
i can use my rook and activate it from
where it currently sits
yeah a3 is nice because the queen on d2
is well positioned but
bishop h6 actually using your idea why
not get rid of that bishop i mean black
only has two pieces developed right now
and you're ready to remove both of them
yes and you're ready to go try to
checkmate that king
if black's not looking carefully so i do
like this decision by
tanya it's really in the flow of the
game here she went knight d5 bishop h6
you're playing active chess and actually
after knight f6 black has to take with
the
pawn on f6 but that could go to black's
benefit
because with this strong center for
white if you can play
f5 but you have a second pawn behind it
to shield your king
then this could help break open the
position and white's pieces the knight
e2 the bishop one f1
they're not fully developed either yeah
nice nice thing about
uh f6 is that you pretty quickly go
rookie
f5 and you just challenge that center
black is also going to probably think
about moves like c5 knight c6
put pressure on the dark squares so it
feels like with c5 and f5 there's really
good wing
counter play and some nice bayonets to
use against the center
for sure and i like that bayonets um and
the thing about playing c4d for e4
that's a dream come true
for most queens pawn players but then
you think about the consequences
whenever you have
pawns two squares apart e4 and c4 the
square in between
could be your opponents for taking so i
like your idea of playing for c5 knight
c6
and if you can somehow get this knight
off the board that dark square is
permanently blacks for the taking
yeah and why not like actually both of
those moves
look pretty okay to me c5 and f5 don't
know which one i would actually go for
but
c5 with knight c6 into knight d4
has a has a good ring to it yeah and so
i don't think white wants to play d5
because the side that controls the pawn
breaks is off the side with the
advantage but if you play d5
no longer can white break open the
position but black has this f5 move
to challenge white's center so i think
that i would either
say rook d1 maybe even castle queen side
because that side of the board doesn't
seem like it's opening up yet
but i would probably just try to keep
the tension for at least another turn
and use the d file to my advantage
and the the time situation almost speaks
to
uh someone who's in exactly the position
that tanya is someone who hasn't
played a ton of uh online chats it's
it's just sort of that
that tournament shape it's kind of hard
to describe but if i haven't played an
over-the-board tournament for a year
and i just go back and play even if i've
been studying chess in the background
there's that element of
hey i just haven't you know grabbed a 3d
piece in a while
and i haven't been under pressure the
way that a tournament might make me feel
and uh these matches i think every
player who plays in them the i am
not a gm tournament they always say like
man that was more stressful than i
that i thought it was going to be i
think i heard that from levy especially
you know the guys streaming
all the time always playing in front of
an audience and when it came to the
match she was just like
not ready for that type of pressure so i
think that's what we're seeing from
tanya is she's taking
so much time to make moves that i think
she knows like the back of her hand
yeah and i think the biggest thing is
not blunders right when you're
rusty at this level it's like all of a
sudden you're going to blunder your
queen
it's more so that you're not feeling the
flow of the game as well so
you may make a decision uh slowly when
you could have played that move in two
minutes you'd make it in
is it classical chess of course and you
make it in ten minutes but there's also
moments where you make a quick move and
you don't
understand or don't quite foresee the
repercussions and now you have a target
that your opponent can exploit or weak
square
that's your opponents to use and look at
this move by cosine knight d7 he's
keeping the position
closed complex and that should bode well
for a person who is up
a minute and a half on the clock and yet
i'm sitting here i love
tanya's position i think she's handled
this well she took on c5 now when she ha
she controls the d file and after this
move i'm already looking at like queen
d6 knight to d5
trying to march my queen into the
position and go after
black here yeah i think uh i think
my instinct is is kind of like just to
play a move like king b1 or bishop e2
eventually get the knight in queen d6 i
guess you could
uh play weirdly brook a6 yeah rook a6
would be doing i
love this move g3 yeah big fan
because there are there are so many
positions where you would maybe never
take
gh but this is a position where you
can't wait to do that
because hey i'll use that g5 i'll play
h5 and you have a second
h pawn which is nice because you're just
trying to break open the file so you go
gh4h5
and then black says i'm not letting you
uh take me and put g5 eventually
play h4 with that second pawn and cause
problems for the black king so tanya is
playing this really well
kostya trying to drum up some counter
play b3 to my eyes has to be the move
i'm not opening up that rook on a8 to
attack my
king side the queen side so i think
b3 but b there's a hard move to play
psychologically right you like look at
those dark squares
if that queen for black gets the e5
there could be a quick checkmate but she
plays it
she has it's covered and is he gonna
launch something kind of like ludicrous
with f5 and just like
rush the queen to to f6 um
you might have to it doesn't well
actually f5 i play rook g1
please play queen f6 please play queen
f6 knight h5
check the g pawn is pinned and richie
wants a movie you want to play
regardless so
perhaps f5 is you know you're trying to
strike
back but you're actually helping white
initiate this
attack slow development like kind of
such a weird
position both sides haven't fully
completed
uh development it seems like but uh
we sort of see what each side wants to
do there's h5 and that f5 move
the funny thing about f5 is that the
best move is absolutely rook g1 but
apart from rook g1
there's not a lot of other good moves
that's true and rooks you want threats
rook takes g6 right now because 96
is a fork and do you really want to go
play queen takes h4 i'll
take your pawn to f5 okay king h7 there
has to be some
quick checkmating attack here h5 comes
to mind what are you doing
five e6 oh looks nasty because you can't
even take that one
oh that's wonderful and you don't get oh
no oh
yeah you deal with this though uh oh and
i think
perhaps she was looking at f takes g6
with check but then her knight on f4
would be hanging because the rook on the
f8 would open up to that knight
so yes oh no yeah this is
definitely oh bishop comes to f5 this is
this is bad
wait bishop f5 there's bishop d3 this
might survive for now because
you win white's queen but black's queen
is hanging with check
on f6 wow because knight d3 is not a
check knight takes f6
with check hopefully smokes
whoa but i i do agree that something
felt like it was going right for kosia
and
tying down under 20 seconds but she's
seeing some tactics here and that's
she's saving her king by this move
bishop to d3 which looked impossible
because under other circumstances it
just loses immediately for white but
that queen on f6 is hanging
at the end of the variation yeah because
if this queen moves i mean you're just
pre-moving bishop takes f5 basically
queen c2 and there's no way that that
queen can get back on that dangerous
diagonal
that's right and the queen on c2 it even
threatens black's king
because if the queen stay on the board
there's h5 and i'm going to go try to
win your g6 pawn but costa simplifies
and now it's even material and in fact
black could scoop up a pawn not yet you
don't want to
trap your knight or get a pinned so
closely i would consider taking that by
the way
i don't know how crazy that is but rook
takes d4 you take on b4
and you get these two pass pawns it can
be hard sometimes to coordinate these
rooks in a position like that
yeah i think that's where you fight your
traditional classical chess instincts
where rook takes before you probably
think it's bad
but in blitz getting past pawns is a
great thing so i'm with you
on that that would have given white
great chances to win and
how i'm looking at this game and seeing
how it might end i think there will be a
nice sacrifice for black and then those
pawns on the queen side will go promote
that's one the a3 pawn is is so close to
queening even though it can't move
it's it's such an asset in positions
like this
and brook f6 is a big move because that
night
tied down to the f7 pawn rook d8 is
quite passive
that's true and king e3 played bringing
the king maybe up the board at some
point but i don't think you can get away
with it like you your king probably
can't march too far
and now costa is able to oh it doesn't
take that h4 pawn
yeah he wanted to like maybe knight e6
is a nice covering move
rook h8 i really like now knight f5
again
yeah and now vert takes h4 comes and the
h2 pawn is under threat
it's so interesting because the c5 pawn
is like the easiest pawn in the sense to
fall but now that black is active the a2
pawn is the most important pawn
and yeah look at this rook b2
can't take that one knight d4 94 knight
takes b3
that's how it's gonna end rook takes f2
and i think b3
oh man and you know talk about
foreshadowing knight v3 may as well even
cover the c pawn why not
yes and well how many extra points two
of your pawns is there any chance that
white can hold this i don't think so
but maybe there's a way to go after this
b4 pawn
the problem is there's a pass pawn for
black and not for white on the other
side of the board that's the issue
yeah oh okay knight d5 that's all you
need
to make sure you don't drop that pawn
and now even f pawn that's going to run
too yeah knight c6 knight takes b4 is
not enough
and i think that'll probably be it
for game number two and that is 2-0 for
costa and if we look at the
you know the nature of these games so
far
it seems like they sort of have the same
pattern just like a really
kind of slow methodical game but this
one had these fireworks at the beginning
that were out of nowhere tactics tactics
ablaze
and that's where tina's time consumption
is coming back to haunt her she spent
a lot of time and she was playing good
moves
but then at that critical moment she
allowed that swift queen f6 95
and that's the biggest difference is in
the first game
coz just simplified there were no queens
on the board it was a rook in game where
he was pressing and it was uncomfortable
for black
in the second game he retained chances
because the queens remained on the board
and he was able to poke some holes in
tanya's queen side and that's where her
king was
yep absolutely and here we see a
trompowski actually
um d4 bishop g5 characterizes
that opening um it sort of looks like a
london
usually when i see players do this
robert i'm i'm kind of expecting them to
go
c3 followed by f4 when i see them like
not develop the
the f or the uh the g1 knight and it
becomes an
essentially an improved stone wall in
many regards because in stonewall with
that f4 move
if your bishop's on c1 it's behind the
pawn structure so it's not
acting with the full scope of a bishop
on h4
well that actually is attacking things
right the f6 knight you can capture at
some point
and white wants to play knight f3 and go
for an attack on the king side so i
like how this has turned out for costia
yeah and i'm just having flashbacks to
chess as a
as a child robert the stonewall is like
that was the being of every
kid's existence everyone has had someone
go like knight f3 knight e5
and you you know you take it f takes you
just get checked maybe that's just how
it goes
it's true right the first time you see
like i'm doubling your pawns
and then white's like yeah please do
that because my pawns get more advanced
and help in the attack and costa has
castle that bishop on b7 that
french-like bishop behind
your own pawns here and that's what
could have happened to white's dark
square bishop but
in this move order the second move was
bishop g5 so that's why the bishop's
outside the chain
and one quick thing amman what do you
make of the fact that kosia did switch
his opening
yeah that's that's actually interesting
um because usually when
something goes well you're not that
interested in switching it
especially when you when you have a game
that in my opinion went as smoothly
as the first game did for him so that's
pretty interesting i think he's just
showing
already that you know she can't get too
comfortable and one thing that
um i don't know if this is something
that
is actually true or not but what i've
noticed is that in bullet matches
if you play a different opening people
sometimes forget
how bad one opening was at the beginning
and then when you play it again later
they go right back into it without even
thinking
so maybe there's some element of that
involved as well
yeah that is funny it's true that does
happen you just have we you're trying to
focus on what you usually play
and then you forget wait a second that
didn't work out so well the first time
then
that punishment is forgotten so the
knight is on e5
this looks very promising for white but
i think many people who are watching say
why is it so promising not a single
piece has been traded white is more
active right the knight e5 has
is the farthest piece up the board and
the bishop on d3 is better than the
bishop one b7 bishop b7 stairs into your
own pawn
bishop d3 stares in both directions and
can help launch an attack
so i just feel like pretty much every
one of white's minor pieces with the
exception being the knight on d2 perhaps
is better than black's counterpart yeah
that's
basically it that's a really good
summary there um
the the other thing about this pawn on
h6 is it always makes
a move like f6 or f5 maybe at some point
a little
harder to accomplish because of the
weakness on the g6 square and that's one
of the main
things you think of you're like seeing
this knight on e5 you're like man get
the hell out of my
out of my position f6 is the first and
main move you would think of
but it's never that easy with that pawn
on h6 so i'm looking at this 995
thinking it's very secure piece
i'm also looking at the time advantage
and saying this time
advantage is completely reflective of
what robert and i are describing right
now
which is a very bad position for tanya
and i i just think that costia almost
tricked her in the opening
bishop d3 knight d2 and whenever you see
that that knight still on g1
you get this cheeky f4 in and i think
it's just worked beautifully
yeah now although you can get a bit
lackadaisical with the white pieces here
you just make some moves that look
normal and
the thing is in this particular position
knight df3 was good
but you may at some point just make a
move because you know
it looks good and then you don't think
of the consequence so for example
uh maybe you'll just rush the decision
when the best move for white is c4
that's another idea in this position
is that white can play c form break open
more of the board and i don't think you
should do that because it also
helps blocks pieces out but sometimes
you just make these quick moves and then
you're not really
thinking about the position as a whole
yep
bishop d6 uh i think tiny has had just
about enough of that pin
and she might be thinking about ideas
like knight e4 um that's the one thing
about playing knight f3 for white is you
sort of lose that control of the the e4
square
and cosy plays knight takes d7 and i
think he's looking to basically replace
that knight
on e5 yes and that will help the queen
on d1 because if that knight
recaptures on d7 which you probably i
don't say want to do but you don't want
the double pawns on
f7 f6 but if you take on december the
knight the knight comes in e5 as the
modern was saying and the queen comes to
h5 and that's how we launch
or the g4 a big attack
yeah and i mean queen d7 i'm less
worried about the double pawns as
as black i'm more worried about like
just the tempo that
that i'm giving up so i think maybe take
with the king on d7 and then go king c8
after you've uh moved the rook or maybe
just go the long way well i knew you
were gonna go 95 regardless so i think i
just would have to
rush it it's forest it's first um
very reasonable decision in my opinion
by by tanya like
she's she's trying to put that knight on
on e4 and she's trying to get that f6
movement
but i i don't think that you can do that
because
robert pointed out something important
as soon as the knight moves there's all
these queen
g4 h5s to consider and long castle by
tanya
wow that is that's committal yes and
actually
kosher could have made a clever move and
king h1 was trying to anticipate castle
king's side so g4 g5
but if he played queen e2 that would
have stopped the queenside castle
because
now he plays it but if i'm black i'm
playing c4 i'm closing that side of the
board
and i'm going to play rook d to g8 and
g5 i need to get some kind of activity
i know i can't do it right yet but
that's what i'm aiming for
yep this king can sort of tuck itself
away on a7 but i mean just look at this
time
it's not acceptable to be at 17 seconds
this is like
crazy down more than three minutes in a
five minute game
you i mean tanya winning this is uh the
i mean that's gonna do wonders for her
confidence but it hopefully
won't make her think that this is okay
because this is something that needs to
change
for the future that's right and you know
she did
capture on b3 her bishop on b7 remains a
very
poor piece and that bishop d3 forces
some action the a6 bouncing and the b4
i'm just going b4
i'm going bishop a6 i'm i think i can
just go checkmate you
at some point soon you don't really have
help coming up towards the queen side
yeah and look how quickly white's pieces
it looks like they're all focused on the
king side
but look how quickly they mobilize
bishop d3 rook fb1
even bishop back to e1 like it's it's
kind of impressive how you can switch
from
king side pressure to to queen side
pressure and just a series of moves
kosia really is playing an excellent
match thus far he's giving
tanya when he is the white pieces he get
he's giving her almost no
play and he is making these really
accurate decisions
that continue the pressure and don't
allow her for any kind of counter play
so
i love the way he's playing thus far she
needs to figure out a
an opening from the black side that
makes her feel more comfortable because
she can't spend this time as we're
talking about
i saw her um connection dipped to
red just for a moment there so i'm
wondering if that's uh
if that's something to think about but i
mean
that was a game that i don't think she
had any chance in it was like plus
nine at the end and i don't even think
he had
taken material yet like i don't even
think he was that material in the final
position
no he wasn't it's just that kind of game
where
we've all had those you just make normal
looking moves honestly that's what she
did
and all of the coaches had a purpose he
gained space
he was able to attack on both sides of
the board and that was a smooth victory
so
now she's down three nothing among
there's still plenty of time left in
this match
and because of how quickly that game
went i feel like we're gonna get more
games
overall throughout this co uh this match
as compared to some of the previous ones
yeah and that's that's what's gonna
happen when one of the players um
consistently gets in time trouble is
that there's going to be
you know two three minutes um in some
games
on kostia's clock that he's just not
using uh
and it seems like he always has that
advantage whether or not his position is
good because we saw
tanya in game number two she actually
had the upper hand and she was playing
some really accurate chess
but the time was still reflective that
she was lower on the clock
than ghost yet so it doesn't seem to
have as much to do with the position
it's more like just a general thing that
if as we see in the opening right now
just the speed from from kosia to start
this uh
this opening off it's just a lot faster
in general
right and if tanya were more informed if
she'd been playing more frequently she'd
make a move like d5 this is a blitz game
right you you may look at
can i take on e5 should i leave the pawn
where it is i would just play d5
and try to take over some space and i
understand it's not a winning move it's
nothing close that we're still
on move nine at this point but you play
the move d5 so that you can serve time
for later in the game and this is what
is commonly said
in blitz chess a good move played
quickly
is better than the best move played
slowly and right now she is a minute
down the clock
and yeah and that's just not acceptable
like uh plain and simple you can't
can't think for a minute here there's
lots of decisions uh to make there's
lots of uh
okay choices d5 to me uh just also from
a uh
the perspective of the move that was
just played makes a lot of sense because
usually after d5 the plane is f5
for black and when i see rookie 8 i know
that black probably wants to play rook
back to f8 and then f5 so
i would even view that as uh as a nice a
nice reason to play d5
and look at this d takes e5 instead of
reacting to the pawn e5
coaster goes knight g4 and now i think
titus is going to go into another
thing because well that threatens to
take this bishop on e3 and you stack
white's pawns there those are not good
the bishop on g7 likes to slice through
the board once this
pawn e5 is out of the way so playing
against the king's indian
d5 for white had made sense but now
we're getting into a tactical position
where tony can go up two pawns
temporarily by taking on d6
but she's down two minutes and this is
such a hard decision
i can't think of many people who would
play e takes d6
and even if they did there's no way
they'd do it quickly um
there's other moves like bishop g5 but
it looks like queen b6 has a nice
response
hitting f2 hitting b2 and she decides to
go queen takes d6
so look if you want this position i
assume
she's playing a good queen takes the
eight because there's no way you can let
the queen stay on in this position
right and all things considered this is
a decent position for white
i would prefer to have the black side
because white is going to be up
two pawns but those are three in a row i
just give one more let's play connect
four let's change the game we win
but these pawns are really poor
two of your extra pawns are the e4 and
the e5 pawns
and you're stuck defending them i think
it's much easier to play this position
for black but as i say that
at a certain moment you start being like
wait a sec i want my material back and
and
i don't have another plan besides to win
back the pawns so perhaps
tanya with some accurate moves here she
can actually seize an advantage
yep um rook e8 was played
not only to get on the e-file and start
targeting some of these pawns but
um also to maybe avoid some trades it's
not necessarily clear
uh the white rook can't get into the
seventh
rank at all so it's not too important i
think to control that open file at the
moment
and knight c5 has been played now one
thing that could go wrong
for costia and what you're kind of
hoping for as
as tanya is you get some sort of b4 c5
and you know
plant a rook or a knight on d6 that's
the dream um whereas cosi is looking to
meet that with
knight d7 and knight takes e5
once you if you if you lose that e5 pawn
in a way that doesn't cost black
anything
then that's going to be a big problem
but that's why she went knight d4 she
realized
your plan and this is great this is
really great by tanya
because the plan was knight d7 knight
takes c5 knight d7 now
drops a piece because of knight takes e6
removing the guard
of this knight on d7 so actually what
she just did there was extremely clever
and
very strong yeah and i i think c5 as a
follow-up
is is not unreasonable opening up the
bishop as well there's going to be
the c6 a6 the b-pawn is overworked
defending both of those things
so that definitely looks uh like
something you could start with king f2
comes to mind as well
you just need to play you're down three
minutes c5 she knows it's a good move
she has played it
but she's down nearly three minutes and
it was a good lesson right there though
in when you're up material in this case
two pawns sometimes you want to give
back
some of that extra material to make the
rest of your position better so she
gives up her e5 pawn to improve her
knight to d4
her queen side pawns start rushing up
the board with b4 and c5
and now she needs to come up with
another plan and she really doesn't have
that much time
and this knight wants to go to you know
c4 d6 has that
that uh desire but knight d2 i mean d4
just hangs to start things off and
i don't see how this knight is getting
back into the action so easily
i would consider playing knight takes e6
and trying to make a draw they go
like an opposite colored bishop's
position to minimize the risk
she's down over uh what
three minutes on the clock right now
three and a half minutes and there she
does
she needs to get on the scoreboard she
needs to convince herself that she is
fully in this match and knight takes e6
take on d8 rook d1 and just say
i'm not losing this game yeah i i almost
i almost think at this point after rook
d1 that
that was the best practical decision as
as you've outlined with
30 seconds is kosi gonna take this well
the thing is if he doesn't
we've been talking about rook d7 the
whole time how hasn't been possible
now it would be so i think he did have
to do that
and now white is still up a pawn and i
would try to
play bishop g4 and maybe even take that
knight on e6 because
in certain end games and bishop v3 is a
similar idea
some end these end games the knight is
actually better than the bishop because
yeah oh
oh no so not only did she drop h2 yeah
definitely gonna lose now i feel like
yeah bishop e6 was like a really good
really good opportunity to to maybe not
even hold the draw but
even entertain thoughts about winning
yeah the knight is better than the
bishop and
this exact type of position because it
can go from color complex to color
complex now
there is a dark spot bishop there is the
this h pawn so if you can trade off
certain
pieces you can leave black with a dark
sword bishop and the h5 pawn and still
make a draw so
i know i say this often people have
rolled their eyes but that is one of the
things i'm considering here as a way to
hold but
costia is just making progress with
every move it seems like
kind of looked like on the last move
like bishop c3 looked like it won the b
pawn i don't know if that was a moment
there white just played king d3 though
so now e4 and c3 are both covered
yes and oh look at this she she
regrouped well knight to c4 and if
bishop
g3 or something like that she can
consider even playing pawn
e5 knight to d6 and going after the f7
pawn
i would go f6 yeah you gotta cover d6
and putting that pawn on a dark square
is definitely
not something you'll be upset with and
it's the same thing but in reverse right
we talked about how the knight can bend
the bishop if knight takes e5 f takes e5
that knight and g5 cannot be dislodged
from that square
black's pawn structure is better because
what is the double e pawns and so this
is what
kosi would like to see happen please
take me on e5
very impressive uh very impressive
defense i i have to say by
by tanya she's very much in this game
and every move that i see happens so far
i feel like she's getting closer and
closer to that draw
yes and look at her bishop dominating
this knight an idea has nowhere to go
and it had gone somewhere else like h6
should have put bishop on e6 so
she's playing this pretty much perfectly
and how did
this is the same blunder as before which
is why i don't think she noticed it
because
i think there was a moment where kelsey
didn't play this move and now
now it's probably over and this is this
well it's the third time but the second
different pawn
that she didn't realize was under threat
from this bishop the dark side bishop
stole the h2 pawn
and then now it went over the b4 pawn so
there was just the time trouble
was influencing her and surprisingly you
can probably take this knight as black
although
there's like no no way that that's my
first
uh consideration i see what you're
saying though because if you trade off
all the minor pieces black wins you pass
pawns on both sides of the board so
bishop d4 ed ford knight to e6 and i
wouldn't do that and i don't think oh
he doesn't help because 96 knight
f4 is also an idea after king e3 you can
just go knight f4
and actually when white's pawns can't
move either right d5 you can't be played
because c5 pawn hang so he
goes and plays g4 and so h3 next
wow very impressive just realizing that
d
and e there's can't move at all there's
nothing happening here
no and i think you can just go h3 that
pawn's trying to
i would probably consider b4 so like if
bishop b7
that maybe i have like b3 to sort of
sneak by
that bishop um but i think h3 just works
as well
as you said but i like your b4 move
because that way you
sort of keep that bishop tied on d5
as you're trying to push your pawns on
both flanks over there but it's hard to
give up that b7 pawn i feel like
even if it works it's not easy but costa
he's been calculating very well
bishop takes b7 if he goes h2 you have
to e5 and
we're trading off many of the remaining
pawns
yeah but c5 falls i guess um
still i'm i'm very suspicious of this
conversion well that move is probably a
losing move bishop d5 had to be played
yeah
d5 is great keep the king out of e6 and
the good thing about a bishop is it very
quickly can go to the other side of the
board so by keeping the bishop on d5
wow and this is over ready but the king
could have made a decision to go to
after either pawn whichever one you
could have tried to win
and that that game was actually really
really impressive by both sides i have
to give full credit to kostya i mean
he's got a 4-0 lead in this match
um it is uh it is super impressive by
him
but that one move bishop d5 if tanya had
found that
it would have been a totally different
game and she might have held that draw
robert
yeah but so far so good for costa
kavutsiaman i've been very impressed
with his play
it seems like he's sharp today i don't
know if he what he did what he ate for
breakfast but
he's in great form right now yeah
absolutely and and we're coming to the
uh
the first halftime break of the uh the
five minute portion so
hopefully you guys can uh uh stick
around don't go anywhere
and when we come back we will resume
this match it's 4-0 for kosi right now
robert and i certainly agree that tanya
needs a bounce back so we'll be right
back after this
[Music]
and welcome back everybody hopefully you
didn't stray too far
everyone got a refill of their drink and
uh
maybe the person who needed that break
the most robert might have been tanya
and it could be at a very good time
because the the score opening up already
4-0
and from what i've seen uh two main
story lines that
that i've noticed is that i think tanya
is actually playing really well
kosia might be playing a little bit
better at the moment but
the time situation that tiny's putting
herself in is just not
allowing her giving her an opportunity
to succeed
yeah kostya has played exceptionally
accurately i mean we looked during the
break
these 99 accurate games and
the first one in particular just has me
thinking that i can't
find a better game out there but tony is
playing well that's the thing
she's had her chances but as you're
saying this the fact she spends so much
time in the early going it doesn't leave
her with enough left
to fight back when her position may be a
bit difficult
yeah because let's let's be clear in
that last game she worked from
you know a triple pawn situation and
down four minutes
to nearly potentially holding a draw at
the end if she played bishop d5
and that's all to show that you know she
had just a couple more seconds to
consider
she might have played bishop b5 instead
but it's a time situation that's really
hurting her
and uh you know even players who are the
best in the world at playing with low
time
you don't want to be in that situation
hey if you if you get low on time
then you're a good enough player to
handle it but you never want to be in
that situation
yeah i think part of the issue is that
when players
compete in blitz events they're
typically three minutes so perhaps you
feel like you have all the time in the
world now you five minutes i can spend
time
on move three when i wouldn't do that in
a three minute game so
here we go bishop g5 played she was g6
this time
different opening she did not like what
happened in that stone wall i agree with
her decision
now we're getting more into a modern
type of setup and will kosher play e4
here which i think e4 is the most
principle move
but he prefers these c3 e3 you know
triangle pawn structures
yeah and um i was wondering now that
we've seen the move d5
uh what you know what stops me from
maybe doing it again i mean it
is possible here i do think she's chosen
a better setup but i actually was
expecting
pawn to d6 from tanya to deal with that
knight on e5 that was being planted
there so that's what i was expecting but
we don't see that from rbc d5 do you
think he's gonna go for this f4 still or
just more
knight f3 see the thing is this f4
knight f395 it's not quite as impactful
because the bishop on d3 is blunted by
this pawn on g6
it still is a plan and it's a reasonable
plan and he goes for it but
if i'm tanya i'm not quite as afraid i
would actually be
fine castling kingside but i would also
think about moves like
queen b6 can i sort of counter
against white setup this pawn on e3
feels a bit loose maybe i'll have a
timely knight g4 as well
and that's what i'm trying to grasp
right now like can i play knight g4
right now
and maybe even sacrifice my knight on
the e3 square
so knight g4 and let's say queen e2
feels like the
the way to meet that and then some sort
of like id3 cd4
and you know all the pieces get active
that's what i'm looking at
and yeah she takes first but that
actually helps clear
the square on e3 i wanted to sacrifice
as a king in the center
not my pieces i always do this but still
that's what i was looking for
and do you think um okay so queen there
and that's actually
a move that has some intentions if you
castle
h6 hits that bishop which is guarding
the the f pawn
you know if you move away all of a
sudden maybe queen takes f4 it becomes a
move there
yeah and while 95 says no f4 pawn for
you
i'm just going to block your queen's
path you don't really want to take on e5
because then
the pawn will capture but this is
different if you can quickly play
f6 for black you know move your knight
away from the
f6 square you challenge white's center
so i would even consider
the move knight takes e5 followed by but
if you take with the f on knight g4
isn't threatening anything
no i was trying to quickly well actually
maybe still works i'll go knight g4 and
even if you attack me i'll play f6
it's probably still still okay because
you're saying like if h3 you could just
go f6
right yeah so 98 very similar idea and
i'm actually a fan of 98 if if you want
to choose a less committal
uh decision because the knight g4 taking
a knight g4 as robert
with f6 looks like if you're
miscalculating maybe things get scary
but 98 looks like hey f6 is coming next
move and i love this reroute
knight d6 with bishop f5 and the the
light squares come under your control i
think tanya has
handled this position uh a lot better
and also if you check the clock
i think it's reflective of that and i'm
trying to think which impacts the other
is she playing more quickly because
she's getting into the rhythm of the
match
or you know what's the order here of why
the the moves are good versus the clock
situation but
still she clearly thought about it she
played g6 on the second move to make
sure that the stonewall attack
wouldn't be so powerful and now with f6
you have to go knight takes c6 and i'm
wondering if i can go ahead and take
your bishop on g5 and get the two
bishops but
that's also a big choice that you have
to think long and hard about before you
just do
yeah takes takes on g5 i guess
um you're bringing the knight back to
e5 there or something maybe knight b4
yeah the d5 pawn's a little bit soft
there so
hmm i still feel like f6 is right now
for knight takes e6 you can just
take back on c6 that yeah yeah b takes i
think you can still continue then with
knight
d6 and bishop f5 i get the impression
once these light square bishops trade
with a knight on d6 that that black's
just doing well no matter how the
position looks like
kick things out with f6 knight d6 even
right now um i'm liking tiny's position
but i'm not liking
the minute she just spent on this move i
shouldn't have complimented her
time robert it's my fault no i just
one of these days where every single
move you're overthinking and she does in
fact put 96
and i've seen the evaluation bar it
changes pretty much nothing
the engine agrees so she spent a minute
23 seconds
she could have played that in 23 seconds
or even less
yeah and let's be clear when she played
98 uh she knows
and we know she knows that knight d6 was
her plan
uh from from minute one as soon as uh
knight e8 was played but
it was more just the overthinking and
hey uh
you know white's actually allowed me to
play f6 is this something i should be
going for
um whereas knight d6 her original plan
turns out to be the one she goes for it
turns out to be a great move by the
engine
yes and it's the big difference of
let's say commentating and playing i
always say this when i'm commenting i
can make
all these suggestions and then if it's
bad nothing happened i just
don't say oh this is why it's bad and i
take it back in a game
you're double triple checking because if
that move is bad
you lose the game and so exactly she
plays knight d6 she probably was
thinking was f6 possible there
spent a bunch of time doing that and now
f6 again
is possible because you give up d5 with
check but you can play pawn e6
stopping the check attacking the queen
that takes your pawn now the knight on
e5 and bishop and g5 are hanging
so i think f6 is a forcing move but a
good move from black's point of view i
think it's a great move and i don't
think it's that hard because like after
queen d5
e6 there's not much else to calculate
there's just a whole bunch of hanging
pieces
um and i imagine after king h8
it's technically probably also still
playable because like
things are still hanging there so point
being i think f6 should be on her radar
from last move
and queen f3 shouldn't change that now
imagine that
she doesn't play f6 i'm trying to wonder
what move she's going to play and i was
about to say
i think she's going to consider e6 to
defend that but i think that's
definitely the wrong idea that bishop
wanted to get to f5 so badly
yeah this is going to be a problem for
black because the bishop is now
blockaded by its own pawn queen h3
taking advantage of black's last move
you played e6 your bishop no longer
hits across the diagonal i play queen h3
why is queen h3 good maybe i'll play
bishop h6
and maybe i'll bring my rook up to f3 so
first my queen then my rook
and black doesn't have too many
defenders on the king side so she needs
to figure out
can i play f6 now but after f6 now
there's knight takes g6 as a possibility
going for like a quick checkmate
against that kingdom yeah knight g6
looks
very dangerous after f6 um there's so
many things to think about there there's
like
e5s in the position but no she's not
going to bite on
any of those i mean this rook can swing
over to the middle
g4 always keeps a knight out of f5 so
i don't think cosia's ever worried about
that right maybe knight g4 ideas
yeah i like knight g4 because now f6
really is a threat at long last
f6 will be the move played if tanya had
a free move so knight g4
doesn't prevent f6 from being played but
it doesn't allow block to fork the minor
pieces either
yep definitely i think bishop h6 also
makes
some sense i mean that's eventually
after f6 after knight g4 you would
probably go bishop h6 anyway so
i think bishop h6 is still reasonable as
well and played
so you called it and i think f6 you know
it doesn't change much here if you oh i
okay i guess f6 now knight f5 comes with
tempo so you can play this move order
but i
something about taking on h6 always
worries let's play f6 robert and i are
cheering for f6 for so long
i think defensively you need that move
and i'm very happy to see it on the
board
so am i and i wonder if this knight has
to move you mentioned the knight comes
f5 white can play g4
can costa just play g4 here and have the
position completely open up
and how how crazy it's like g4 you take
here and you can just take
back f takes e5 and he decides to go
bishop takes and
wow i'm looking at this position robert
and i'm seeing e takes f5
i'm saying hey that's my e4 square and
you know what that's also my e5 square
that's not something you get to say
every time when you play against these
um i guess these stonewall setups and
she decided to say with the knight i
liked your decision to take with the
pawn either pawn aussie even g takes f5
at least possible but she takes the
knight and her position is still
looking pretty good her clock is not
though she's 23 seconds
to her opponent's minute and a half and
it's not exactly clear what black's plan
is going to be are you going to go for
a5 b5 b4 is the threat bishop b5 right
now to
pin this knight on d3 but if you move
that bishop e6 becomes a bit more tender
is white going to play g4 and g5
because the dark squares should come
under white's control because it's a
light square bishop
against some knight so i would actually
try for g4 and if i can make it work
then g5 but i understand that black lost
with an e5 tactics
i'm not calculating that right now too
much yeah i i would
go for instinctively i would go for
something like g4 maybe move the queen
to like g3 or g2
and then try to go for g5 but um i'm
keeping in mind that you know even if
that happens and e5 isn't a tactic if
black plays like f5 and 94
that's also fairly reasonable um okay
queen g3 played so i think g5 is on the
horizon here
tough to deal with with only 18 seconds
on the clock and bishop c6 i think
bishop b5 would have been my choice but
she's trying to play 94 so
she has clear purpose to her moves and
if 94 happens
well i can get my pawn on e4 play f5 and
try to improve my position this manner
yeah no totally understand here so i
would play some sort of b6
a5 moves to to take some night squares
away
but i'm on this bishop on c6 if that
knight gets a dark square it should be
five
yes bishop b5 is begging to be played
get it the hell out of there
i think you could play it next move that
night doesn't really have any we're good
because f4 is hanging yes and bishop b5
now
go after the knight you are going to be
struggle in the long term if you do not
take this knight
a5 i understand it it's a good move but
we're screaming for bishop b5 and oh no
like bishop c8 i don't know what it does
it was is if the point is to go bishop
a6 then that could have been done a long
time ago but look at this then i found
out this is
this is bad now i think it's just lost
even though
black's not down a single piece white
has no threats right now
but the knight can come in g4 to f6
simon queen h4
king up to g3 just to protect the f4
pawn and bring some rooks to the h file
i think he's gonna go like king g2 maybe
rook f2
and there goes 96 check wins not h6 wins
the rook but he knows that it wins the
rope no matter what it's actually just
trapped
he doesn't even want the rook honestly
okay i i like the moves
uh from tania she knows she's losing the
rook there's nothing she can do about it
right um c4 there's queens one i'm
looking for one
yeah rick f1 was strong there that's
okay
so how does this black get in this if
that bishop sneaks in
anywhere here then it could be really
good for her
two seconds one second we need to move
wow point four left
yeah if that bishop could someone get to
e4 block his chances but
no chances oh my goodness
i feel i feel like these positions are
like she
right when we uh we feel like she's back
in the game
i i take a look at the clock and i'm
like oh no there's like 15 seconds left
because she defends these positions so
well but
the clock she's not putting herself in a
position to succeed
no she's not and she has played some
very good games
she was playing a very good game that
one and then she didn't have time left
to figure out
how to proceed the bishop didn't get out
the knight
dominated the dark squares so she needed
to play move like bishop to b5
and it's just clear that the match is
getting to her at this point she's down
five nothing
she needs one game just one victory
as soon as she gets that victory i think
things can fall into place but we're
already getting to the point where it
could be
not too little too late there's so much
time left in the match including this
five minute portion but
you know you it doesn't feel good to
start down half uh
no it definitely doesn't and we're also
seeing the most amount
of games that i've seen at least in the
five-minute portion
i you you mentioned this right at the
start of the match was like
uh based on the time that tanya is
is uh spending on her moves uh kosia is
finishing a lot of these games with
multi minutes on the clock
and so we're actually getting more
volume of games in this five minute
portion
and this line robert i i
hate this line i play the the sameish i
dislike this with the passion black goes
e5 and then goes like d5
and just says hey you know what you
calculate it
don't don't tell me to do a mon where
are your co-commentators here but
yes that is the theme of this position
black's play is
in the spirit gambit and stuff like that
where you lose a pawn
sacrifice it and then you have all these
open lines and whether that's using the
b
file opening up the center like it's an
e5 d5 you need to be so
precise here from timer's perspective
to just avoid losing in the next 10
moves because your king's in the center
and
here i think you can just be knight c5
three knight to b3 the acon is pinned
thanks to the fact that black does not
have an a pawn so very quickly
black's pieces are coming into play and
white is several tempi down
in development exactly um you know white
has
the dream of this position where it's
like takes knight takes other knight to
c3 bishop c4
it's a beautiful grip on the light
squares especially because this pin is
not something you can get rid of very
easily h6 can always be potentially
taken
um reminds me of these like positions
where you go h6 bishop h6
knight takes e4 with the tactic queen h4
winning the bishop on h6 and suddenly
all the dark squares fall so
maybe h6 can be played actually yeah
it's it's those kind of lines are very
interesting
and of course you end up taking d5 the
one thing i'll say
is now they're both feel like they're in
neutral territory where
they're out of the opening stage
they have about the same amount of time
kosia is not and he does play h6
so i think i think you almost have to
take and just play on the light squares
yeah that makes sense and it's in the
spirit of a sicilian
except for the fact that white is
already up a pawn so i think
you like you said take on f6 knight c3
and so on but if you did this
this is the wrong move order you should
have left the knight on d5 and taking f6
with the bishop right away
and just went knight e2 to c3 and so on
and the problem here
is after bishop f6 bishop f6 knight c3
black gets to play bishop e6
and white doesn't have bishop c4 as a
follow-up so it's maybe not the most
consequential thing
it's just a point of frustration and i
think
knight f6 looks like a move played by
someone who maybe just overlooked
uh bishop h6 knight e4 and noticed it
later because
in hindsight i'm sure she would prefer
to play bishop takes f6 first and then
the bishop e3
it's going to be d5 and black is doing
very very well here yes
and you can even sacrifice the exchange
i'm sure and go for the initiative but
you can play
rookie and keep it simple if you don't
want to drop some material but
yeah i think i think that d e is it's
almost not even a sacrifice because it's
damn near like
theory or something like that if if
white does this in general against d5 in
this line
you just always sacrifice it so that's
one of those sacrifices almost like
you're telling a grunfeld player to
sacrifice the exchange it's like okay i
was going to do that anyway
yeah it is just like that the sicilians
sacked that rook on c3 for
a knight absolutely and here look at
this just take bishop b7
black's pieces have all these natural
scores to work with
and white's king will not find shelter
no matter if it stays in the center or
goes in either direction
that king is going to be in trouble
yeah and just such a solid king position
for cosia so
it's it's you know knight h5 knight uh
f4 bishop b7 bishop e6 are the first
ideas to come to mind queen c5 is a nice
centralizing move which kind of makes
white think twice about castling in
either direction
yeah this is much easier for black to
play but you just mentioned all these
moves
perhaps being spoiled for choice causes
some paralysis of like
wait i i which one is the most precise
because at the end of the day
chess players especially these strong
players here they want the truth of the
position they don't want to just
you know make these split-second
decisions that may not be accurate i
think kosher wants to find the perfect
move at this point and now he's thinking
he's about to be even on the clock does
he put his rook on d8 or is it better to
play queen to c5 and if i play queen c5
well why play queen f2 and
you start questioning can i trade queens
or must i keep them on the board because
i'm down in exchange all these questions
swirl in your mind
it costs you time on the clock and for
costia he has a great position
but in the back your head is i'm down
some material so i
actually need to make sure that i'm not
dilly dallying and allowing my opponent
to take over an open file for example
and can we talk about tanya's first lead
on the clock in the entire match
i don't care what the position is this
is a good sign tanya needs to be
hopefully she's thinking on kosi's clock
not
kostya available look at that tanya
spent 13 seconds
in previous games she would have spent
45 seconds a minute on that move castle
she is making sure that she will have
enough time to think after this because
castle
is not losing right away it could get
her into some difficulties maybe this
pawn for black
is going to e3 next but at least she has
time to figure out the next stage of the
game
yeah that's a great point that's just
blitz for you you can't calculate
every possible repercussion after e4
she's not sitting there wondering you
know
what happens if it gets to e3 long term
is that good or bad
she just canceled 13 seconds that's a
great decision
king h1 not uh not going to play queen
f2 and walk into e3
so now e3 and she's gonna have to to
think just do i want to blockade with
the queen run into bishop a6 or just
queen c2 here
right and for the record i don't really
enjoy white's position but if you play
queen c2
and just keep playing quickly you will
have better chances to survive this
queen c2
and knight d5 looks strong the knights
seem to pin to the queen on
c2 so it's not necessarily a fun
position to play but
if you have time left you can spot
tactics f4
yeah i like because i was gonna i was
gonna say f4 maybe after knight d5
so that's why i thought of f4 here as
well just as an answer to knight f4
because knight f4 looks so annoying
and she plays it queen takes g2 and she
could actually
maybe counter against the black king all
of a sudden if a timely f5 for white
happens that could spell some trouble
for the king on june i would not play
that move it allows black by g5 and take
over the f4 square but you want to keep
f5 in your mind because sometimes you
play f5
and after g5 play f6 right you just like
give away that pawn
to try to open up files for your rook
yeah and queen d5 look at the speed from
tony i
i just think the last 10 moves from her
um
have been fantastic just in terms of how
quickly you want to get these moves out
yes and the pichu phone is hanging so
that's a bit of an issue rook a b
one not exactly the move you want to
play black like e2 the f4 pawn is
hanging and feels uncomfortable
uh perhaps you do play f5 f6 and shoot
queen e4 which probably is also a good
move
so yeah takes takes um takes on b2
you don't even really calculate that you
just say look i've got an outside pass
bond there and queens are off the board
that's that's probably a good thing and
so costa he doesn't
want to trade queens queen h4 is a
natural attacking move
but it's easy to meet right quinnish
four the queen goes maybe go back to
uh oh there's queen g2 that's 1924. but
knight f4 happens and
but then you play queen f3 perhaps and
you win the e
but the rook takes p ah so many tactics
i think you can play queen g2 and maybe
you have to play queen g2 yeah
yeah so um is there rook takes
b2 in any way i'm trying to like go
super aggressive
but probably it's just super unnecessary
knight f4 looks solid and good and there
we go oh that's a good move yes
that's a good move by the way i think
the position has to be good for black
though you just trade queens but like
knight d3 and the b2 bombs under attack
fisherman g7
is uh hitting the knight and see the
reason that pawn can move but a4
just go for it right just just go
this is you can't waste time trying to
defend this a4 i don't know knight takes
uh b2 maybe knight e2
plant your knight in front of the pawn
and go like rook a2 and just close your
eyes and go to the promised land a8
that's that's what you have to try for
and with bullet experience you play a4
and hope that it works out it's probably
losing maybe not regardless but you're
gonna be in trouble
no matter what and it could be a losing
move but at a certain point you just
have to go with it and i like work f3
though
yep yeah rook f3 i will say the reason
that i don't like it is because time's
getting low
and it looks like a move that needs some
justification it's going to
discoordinate white's pieces a little
bit
and if she can find the right
calculation
i'm all for it all for it so 92 that's
the move i would play quickly right now
just
get that bishop and then the bishop has
to make a decision do i worry about the
b2 pawn or keep e3 defended
and if i keep e3 defense move now i have
two pass pawns on the queen side so
this is improving for her she's still 20
seconds so she's keeping a better pace
yeah this is fantastic so bishop a7 i
think he might just like
chuck it all the way back there's no way
he wants to give up that e pawn
no and i guess the another annoying
thing is rook d1 is not possible because
there's knight f2 checks with b3 to
start with
so c8 is what i would go for there's
still no rook to
d1 said he brings his back to f1 ooh
okay rook a6 maybe she wants yes she's
probably gonna play rook a6 where's that
bishop going
yep and there could be a mate though if
rook d2 rook takes e2 knight of three
that's checkmate that's a networking one
no knight f3 oh no
oh okay but knife three can't really be
stopped
yeah knight f3 is nasty okay gotta take
that
you have to take it you know knight f3
here we go there
ambrook d1 yeah and then bishop f2 and
you're winning the rook here coaster man
this guy is just on fire
he's on fire he's on fire because this
was
like one of tonya's best games in my
opinion she she handled
uh things while on the clock and on the
board and what did it come down to
just a blunder like one move at the end
um costa is just like if
i'm trying to think of chances where
it's like
you could have won the game against him
i can't think of any i can think of
chances where he could have played a
better move
and maybe put him under more pressure
maybe hope he would have blundered but
robert i'm not seeing any games or any
moments where
kosei was just lost on the board or
anything close to it so far
and i think that he deserves all the
credit of course we keep talking about
time management and how
time tonya's struggling to keep an edge
on the clock it's
been very rare but kosia has been
playing accurate chess it's not like
he's winning games where
he's minus five or he's down at full
rook and then he went on time
no all the games he is fighting and he's
been better in a bunch of them so
i think that kosia has played an
excellent match at this point it is
six nothing tanya she needs to find the
right play we're back
i'm on to game one right you said you
don't go back to something for a while
but here we are back to game one
and now time has to figure out do i play
c5 again
this is exactly what i was talking about
because she's like she's like c5 oh wait
i lost that game really badly and that
was no not fun at all
and she's thinking damn i think i need
to play another move here and she's
going to find one but it's going to take
her a minute
that's already worth it after coast yeah
and coach is still in his
general preparation he's in that
framework of what he was looking for in
the opening
now even though you don't have the
isolated pawn right now it's going to be
difficult
for black to get the move c5 in as is
often the case
though tony's doing the right thing
she's playing quickly just just take
with the queen on d5
play for c5 that's what i would do here
queen d5 queen h5 if bishop c4 it looks
like and then just c5 knight c6
rooks to the the two open and semi-open
files
yes and she's thinking do not take with
the pawn and diva there we go please
don't there we go i like this i like
this
yeah pawn takes d5 would have been
getting her into the exact type of
position she does not want to play
and maybe she's fine playing that in
classical chess but with so
little time on your clock you don't want
that position so
come on she is doing five o'clock i like
black's position here i think that
white's pawn pushes could backfire
whenever you push upon
some squares you're previously defending
become weaker so queen h5
just go yeah
queen h5 um it's not that you
necessarily want to play
bishop takes f3 but you're just setting
things up i mean queen g6 looks super
normal
hitting uh g2 getting out of this uh
this pin but this move i'm not a fan of
it's like white just played bishop e2
for free i'm just gonna back up a couple
moves
and just show like if white plays bishop
e2 here it's black's turn
and if i fast forward to the game it's
actually white's turn in the exact same
position
so uh kostya whether it looked like it
or not he got the upper hand there
he certainly did and now he's making use
of that fact because he's rooks in c1
hitting the c7 pawn
and if you play c5 now the position
opens up and you start thinking about
whose pieces are better that bishop on
b2
is thrilled to see the move c5 so yeah
that was just
an unfortunate decision by tanya i don't
think she should play c5 yet she's
playing rook a to c8
it's not easy she does do that it's not
easy for white to stop c5 so
you just want to time it correctly yeah
even if b4 i mean the the opening of an
extra file
is not going to be too disastrous for
either player really so
including b4 into the c5 calculations i
don't think matters too much
that's right and opening the c file too
early there was a rook on c1 that would
have been
the first rook to take over the file so
now she's just
preempting it she's making sure that
when the file does indeed open
she is rooked to counter white's rook on
c1 and the main difference i see in the
position so far is that minute that she
had to spend to come up with b6 right at
the start of the game
funny enough um both positions i would
take either side here
which is kind of the sign of probably an
equal position
more or less the queen always has h5 if
he gets attacked
i think c5 here is very reasonable um
rook d8
and 84 all come to mind but the thing is
you just got to move
we've been saying this a lot i would
think about rook d8 like you said
c5 maybe bishop d6 knight e4
all these moves are possible just just
pick one
just go gotta pick one it's gonna be
another minute think here
nearly um for tanya she started around
three minutes and she's
closing in on two minutes a5 again good
move
uh tanya has not been short on good
moves this match
robert she has not made uh two serious
uh blunders usually they're like they're
one move and it might be at the end of
the game in time pressure but
when tanya thinks she comes up with good
moves but the problem is i don't think
she needs
all that time to play that good move she
needs to trust herself more and she can
play that same move
you know two three four five times
faster that's right
and another good move here that i'm
seeing is made bishop d6
because i'm going for a cheapo i'm just
going to go knight g4 and take your h2
pawn and then meet you with my
bishops across the board that's kind of
thematic in a sense
when you have a control of a long
diagonal you want to go for an attack so
i'm playing bishop d6 to free up my rook
from c8 and i can play c6 later if i
want but i'm just trying to attack
the white king yep uh c6
also makes a lot of sense after a5 so i
feel like c6 bishop d6 are the first two
moves that come to mind
even c5 if you want to like just force
the issue with
with ampassa so c pawn or bishop here is
what i'm thinking if if rook d8 comes
i'm a little bit concerned about
you know like bishop c4 95 kind of stuff
and and white taking over that c6 square
and down two approaching two and a half
minutes
robert it's just not going to cut it
against costa here bishop d6 another
good move but
too much time spent a full minute plus
coming up with that move and she saw
that instantly right there's no doubt
and that's what
amanda keeps saying is she's playing
good moves she's making good decisions
she's just double and triple checking in
times when she shouldn't do that she's
being a perfectionist queen h5 just go
there we go all right now there's a
threat there's a big threat of bishop f3
so 95 makes sense and they play queen g5
you don't want trade queens you know
that's a bad end game for you uh or
queen in this middle game i say play
queen g5
keep the queens on the board because f3
there's queen e3 f4
well hello you're actually getting mated
there so there's not a good answer g3 i
think
everyone can understand tanya needs no
reminder that that bishop is
gorgeous on that long diagonal after g3
so queen g5
i mean tonya knows it's the automatic
move here we just need to see it quicker
yes and she's thinking here
the thing is you look at this position
if you
oh i would say if you trade queens you
know you're just worse
and then she goes ahead and trades
queens so
i feel like amanda she just doesn't have
the
like it's not the feel of the position
but it's almost like she doesn't believe
in her the what she's intuiting from the
position and so she keeps
thinking for too long and making the
decision that she would never make in a
classical game
yep i think i think that goes back to
just sort of tournament shape game shape
um which was that thing that i was
trying to describe at the beginning but
i was having a hard time doing so
um it's really hard to describe just
being out of shape and
it's like oh no don't worry you've been
studying whatever you know your lines
um tiny is obviously very immersed in
chess
in her everyday life but it's uh it's
the the theory uh being able to play the
beginning moves of the game
way quicker than your opponent jump out
to that minute minute and a half edge
which kocia has protected the entire
match
that's true and i think for those of our
viewers in the audience who are made
newer to chess or
not so experienced you look at this
position say wait why is white better
here
why is double pawns it doesn't seem that
bad for black but bishops just control
so much of the board and this pawn e5
while it is doubled
it's going to help the rook lift into
the d6 square
and then if that rook you can envision
that work on d6 please take me there i
would love it for you to capture me
there and if not
that b6 pawn now is a target i'll put my
bishop on d4
and then play pawn to e4 and directly go
after that i think you just do that
right now rook c8
should be four pawn four and in any
order yeah bishop d4 pawn e4
uh bishop c6 b5 bishop b6 and
robert was just tarping on those bishops
and now you get to see them in action
and the you know bishops work into their
to their maximum
effect uh robert it's a it's a beautiful
thing except if you're tanya in this
position but otherwise it's a beautiful
thing
that's true uh for those of us who have
no nothing invested in the game the
bishops are
fantastic and e4 king e3 king d4 king c5
just don't get four don't allow knight
c6 with the check otherwise this is
going to be quite straightforward uh oh
bishop b4 here is lights out
just take that and bring the king and
even right there you saw kosia pre-move
bishop takes e7
that's a sign of somebody who is playing
quite a deal of blitz because
sometimes you're going to make that move
regardless but he had that pre-moved so
he's understanding the dynamic he's has
expectations for his opponent's move
and he's finding the right response in
advance yeah
yeah and it's now 7-0 and this is going
to be the last
uh five minute game most likely in this
in this section as i see just a minute
ticking down on the match clock but to
get
eight games in the five minute portion
is quite a lot and it speaks to the fact
that most of these games are finishing
when kostya has two minutes three
minutes on the clock
um and you know over the course of seven
games
to have like two x that's like 14
minutes that's two three extra
uh entire games um yep this is uh this
is quite something and and
like i can talk about the time pressure
for tanya
over and over again but i want to make
sure i'm giving full credit to costa
i think he's actually playing an
incredible match right now
so few blunders robert i'm just like
wildly impressed
with the way coast just playing he's
made no blunders at least not that i can
recall and
he's playing very accurate brand of
chess he's playing quickly
i i would like to ask him when this
match over about his preparation because
it does seem
like he thoroughly prepared for it he's
done his research
and he's just finding openings that are
good for him they fit his style but
here's this moment again we've seen this
position
bishop takes f6 knight takes up stick
then knight e2 to c3
you don't give black the same
flexibility because white's bishop now
has the access the c4 square
and so bishop e6 there's a knight in
between those pieces
yep exactly bishop takes f6 knight c3 i
think is
the only other try because she knows
that this stuff is too tricky too
dangerous bishop takes
h6 can't go for that um and knight f6
she tried last time
and i don't think she wants to repeat
that although maybe
spending time here i'm trying to think
maybe i don't see anything else besides
bishop takes i guess bishop h4
to keep the pin up but spending too much
time right now or bishop e3 right away
maybe
the thing up bishop e3 the knight takes
d5 and if the queen takes you feel like
your queen doesn't really want to be on
d5 but you're right d3 is a move to
consider
yeah it definitely doesn't i guess
they're
i feel like in those positions there's
often a uh like a very aggressive way to
play like knight b6
bishop e6 queen v6 sack the rook in the
corner you know
take on b2 get a very very aggressive um
way to play going because that that's
that's usually how these positions go
and
what what a time investment right here
we just need another move and tiny's
racking her brain trying to find
something different than what she did
last time
um but she's also so attached to his
bishop you can tell
um in this opening that's just a piece
you don't want to give up for a night
most of the time
and it's good to be skeptical as a chess
player but i would trust kosuya right i
would just say
uh h6 i can't capture all the stuff he's
playing this opening fast so i just need
to move she does bring her bishop back
to e3
but didn't we see this exact position
that we did earlier
and shooting bishop c5 d takes e4 and
the position quickly collapsed for white
so
i'm not even suggesting that this
position itself well
i was gonna say i don't think it's lost
but this isn't good that's for sure
it's definitely not good and i think at
this point because she's invested now
two minutes
on that that thought process and didn't
come up with anything new she's just
going for the same line because
okay at least i can repeat these moves
you know the next
uh i don't know if kosi is going to play
the same exact way
quite possibly he will but she's looking
to just copy your last moves
to get quick moves out yes and
this is the biggest difference between a
match like this and
tournaments that you see in rapid chess
or classical chess
where in those tournaments you lose a
game you have time to go back
say what did i do wrong how can i
improve so i don't get in trouble again
and then you make those adjustments
there's no time to adjust in this format
and so kosia he just says why not i won
a great game
uh with this opening and look at this
rook v8 we've seen all this before
the b two pawns under attack only black
is a dark square bishop
that queen can come to c5 the bishop is
going to b7 or maybe if it wants to go
to e6
or h3 if the bishop doesn't stay on the
f1 h3 diagonal for white
the flexibility for black here and the
two extra minutes
they speak volumes and look at what a
what a
gamesman coast he is i love his decision
not to play the same line
because he says look you're playing into
the same bad line i think i know what
you're trying to do
you're trying to just repeat the whole
game and maybe improve later on
at some critical moment well i'm just
gonna get you out of
you know your theory so to speak or get
you out of that copycat idea
from last time i'm just gonna play rook
b8 now you have to think all over again
as if it's a brand new position
and you're low on the clock i'm gonna
try to take advantage of that so i think
it's just a
just a great decision and he has five
different good looking moves every
single turn he was queen c5
other ideas that come to my mind include
rook to b4 knight to h5
developing the light square bishop to
any of its squares b7 a6
literally f5 right you have all these
choices but he's making his decisions
in 10 seconds and that's leading him to
kind of win on the board in addition to
the clock so the knights have betrayed
now
something has been clarified bishop a6
you're not castling kingside you're
certainly can't castle queenside so
how do you continue here for what i'm
struggling queen h4
another uh cheeky idea because even
queen f2 you can't just
take that clean up these queen side
pawns afterwards
and that end game only black can win as
well
in addition to queen edition maybe
you'll play bishop f6 bishop h4 and just
go for a checkmate because the king is
stuck in the center you're right that
even without the queens if black can
take b2 and a2
you're winning all the pawns and blacks
in good shape so
i mean h4 i mean i'm just grasping at
straws here but maybe
h4 um because i feel like i don't i
can't
give you that h4 square yourself well
it's too late now rook c3 isn't played
so
bishop f6 to h4 seems pretty powerful
refreshing
especially because you can use h4 g5
so many options and the time is
reflective of how easy the position is
to play
and i think rook c3 was interested in
queen hill which he does play which i
think is a mistake
but it's so tempting to give the
immediate check but look what she's done
she missed
queen f2 if we do in fact get a trade
the
king will land on g3 black will take b2
and a2
i do don't think though that white
should be fine in that position i
understand that black is happy to have
four pawns on two and it's an exchange
down
but there aren't too many pawns
remaining and the rooks get active so i
think that
yeah she can hold that kind of position
i would not trade queens if i'm
closed yet yeah completely agree if that
bishop was like on e6 in that position i
think it'd make a world of
difference but being on a6 it's a little
you know kind of uh
uncoordinated over there and queen takes
f2 makes the position
easier to play and that's what kosia is
thinking about right now i said damn i
don't want to make it that easy to play
she's just going to take her king on g3
double the rooks or whatever like
too too easy to find uh good or decent
moves
so if he just plays a move like i don't
know queen
g5 i'm trying to think what what else to
do but yeah queen g5 played and it's
like okay
doesn't matter if maybe the evaluation
bar is sitting at 0.00
every player in this game including you
and i uh right now robert we know this
game is not
equal and it's not a draw right that's
what's confusing for people they see
zero is like wait isn't that just
equality and you look at the position
how and then you have spent dynamic
equality both sides of chances
but that's why you focused on what is
happening what the pieces are doing
how they're coordinating you know how
they're working in conjunction with one
another and i like black's position
still but
in a few moves this could turn around so
you i i don't even know actually
what black should do right now because i
move like bishop to b7
you're sort of retreating and when i see
bishop b7 i even think
in the corner of my eye like queen a7 at
some moment i wouldn't do that right now
but i'm just looking like watch out
there could be a timely move like queen
a7
that could get you in trouble absolutely
um
you almost want to play yes so bishop b7
played you can see that eval bar
actually creeping up but kosia probably
knows he's lost some of his advantage i
think just because of the type of moves
that have happened over the last
last series here but he also uh i think
will recognize that as long as he keeps
pieces on the board
tanya is going to have to play a
incredibly accurate game
uh in order to keep that that advantage
that the engine is displaying
at the moment and that's a great first
move because queen f7 is a mating
threat and you're putting pressure on f7
you would like to play bishop c4 but
don't make that move too
soon because if you try to play bishop
c4 queen c1 check that rook needs to
stay
in line with the c1 square but actually
how does black respond to rook c7
you can't protect f7 with the rook you
drop your bishop on b7 so
i was going to say i feel like you
almost go like king king age seven or
something
and say look if you want to go down and
grab that pawn with the queen it's not
going to be checked so at least i get in
with some checks of my own and then
maybe i can meet this
uh this checkmate threat myself that's
true you know you could slide a rook to
g8 give up that bishop kind of like what
you were saying earlier
in that line where like queen takes d5
queens day you give up a rook on
the irrelevant side of the board so that
the king and this
in this case the bishop and the king for
white is very unsafe so i think that
you're right that might move like king
to
h7 makes a lot of sense here and great
move by the way i know you you harped on
it but brooks c7
like still covering the c1 square and
being aggressive hitting f7 and b7
that's just a fantastic move and i love
that she's ready for the next move
she plays rook g1 queen f6 this is
definitely trending in tanya's favor and
i think she knows it she's ready to
strike and potentially
score going in to the three minute
portion robert and remember how i said
queen a7 wasn't good then
i think it's good now i think queen a7
is going to win this game like right now
you attend the russian bishop
and honestly there it is this is why i
bring up ideas even when they seem like
they're never going to happen
you want to keep in the back of your
head because if you don't think about
queen a7
you'll just forget about here you'll
focus on the king side i'm going to
checkmate that king well you know how
you can check with the king if your
queen gets involved the queen a7 comes
with tempo the bishop is falling
this is lights out beautiful move and
i i was saying that that could be the
exact momentum she needs going in
to the next format um and look at that
seven losses in a row but fighting chess
every time and tanya slowly seems to be
maybe fixing her mistakes
let's see if she can close this one out
before i jinx it robert
yeah and i mean this is a good
retreating mcqueen to e3 but look at the
bishops trying to come to d4
she takes that that's a smart move she
says nope
yes and oh she didn't see h2 was hanging
it's not the first time today she forgot
about that side of the board
but yep queen c3 okay i like this
this d4 is gonna be played king e3
king e3 is a big time move
okay can you two is played still a good
move yes you might be able to play king
e3 next move too
now you can't play e3 but
i think oh queen h2 queen h2 queen f4
oh my gosh she's so happy that that
didn't happen but queen it's you're
still happening
wait king c354
okay or queen e5 and then the rook hangs
well depends where the king goes now
there's checks and oh the rook just
hangs with check
i don't know what to say oh
no robert i feel horrible
i feel just absolutely gutted
that's so heartbreaking to watch
so heartbreaking to watch
kostya knows he just got away with
murder basically um
and he's got that look on his face like
i didn't deserve that but
it's not like he's been undeserving of
all the games in this match and he's
upbeat out
it's like that was the first one that
that tanya
fully deserved the point and what a
defensive
effort by her to even get to that
position that looks so lost the king was
stranded in the middle
she coordinated all her pieces and it's
just like you get that one moment to
maybe make that small comeback in a
match
and it it just barely slips away yeah
she turned defense into offense very
quickly
and then on the flip side costa said
well she doesn't have that much time
left so let's keep this complicated
and her move rook takes g7 she gives
summer material she was doing the right
thing
but she could never find that knockout
and that probably caused her some
distress
and in the end it cost her not just her
win but it even
caused her to lose oh my goodness well
guys you know the score it is eight
zero for costa kavodski and it's gonna
take
something short of a miracle in the
three minute portion
for tony to get back in this match she
absolutely can but
you know slowly but surely it is
slipping away we will be back
uh we're now at the end of the five
minute portion we'll be back with the
three plus one portion
right after this stick with us
so
[Music]
and we are excited to get back into the
commentary for this match between kosice
kovetsky and tanya sachdev but first
want to remind you
about pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6
which
chess.com is hosting yet another edition
you can see
the participants on your screen there uh
i'm i'm just looking at all these names
robert
and i'm excited to see guys like logic
getting in there we've seen
um the v tuber code miko as well as myth
from uh tsm uh getting involved any
names stand out to you
well you know i've coached some of the
players uh of course
there's some excitement of rain wilson
from the office taking part
and a lot of these players have been
practicing very hard i've seen nico
and michelle in recent days they've been
playing a lot of chess so
i hope they're ready for when the time
comes they're not too nervous they're
all doing a great job
yeah and this will be an exciting
tournament you guys have maybe seen
previous editions of pogchamps so you
know what to expect
not the highest level of chess but the
highest level of entertainment
guaranteed
so that's coming up robert but right now
we've got to focus on
the i am not a gm tournament and the
next format
uh of this this match is gonna be the
three minutes so three minutes plus one
second
um is is this gonna be sort of like what
you were saying robert about how
tanya sees five minutes as i have tons
and tons of time
and playing too slowly is this gonna
wake her up to to playing quicker
i think it will i think it's a more
natural time segment for her and just
for most players in general
and i just want to give credit to costa
kavutsuki because i'm
i was thinking during the break just now
is this the best performance we've seen
in a and i am not gm speeches
championship imagine the
rival performance i would say was john
bartholomew against elena kashlinska
in the final where he went i think six
nothing in the three-minute portion so
this is one of the best performances
tanya is super strong
and she hasn't been playing that poorly
it's not like she's just
allowing him to just win games no he is
really playing
some stellar chess and i it's clear he's
worked hard i think
last year's loss has motivated him to
bring an even better
kosher kavetsky to this tournament yeah
you said it well um kosia deserves all
the credit for sure because he's
managing a lot of different aspects
there's like the whole chess aspect
there's the practical
aspect this is blitz chess and he's also
managing the clock very very well
so he's putting himself in a position
even when he's maybe lost on the board
which has only happened
once in the entire match and is in that
last game he still put himself in a
position to potentially succeed
because of the clock and how tricky he
was able to make the position
that's right and for tanya i mean it
must be painful it must be frustrating
to be in this situation where like
i'm really not playing that badly but
every time i look over and i glance i
have
30 seconds left to my opponent's two
minutes and that's what's
really bogging her down to this point
the opening struggle i think has been
won
by kosia in most of these games with the
white pieces coach just put her in a
tough spot with his trophowski
and also in these kind of queens game of
decline positions and here we see
c4 so instead of these uh lines where
the bishop came out early we're getting
back to our uh
queen's game decline positions yeah and
people need to remember this is a match
between
i was at the seventh and eighth seats so
it's it's right down the middle and if
you look at their ratings now i might
say oh 2300 against 2500
well let's remind people they started at
24.50 each
and costa has been winning all the games
so he's shot right up
and tiny has gone down in the other
direction so this is like on paper
definitely one of the closest matches
and that's why it has to be said that
kosi is putting up one of the best
performances that that we've ever seen
just in terms of the strength of the
players involved
yeah and the winner of this eight nine
matchup goes and plays number one
overall seed greg jihadi and i'm sure
greg
is probably in the chat right now saying
i think kostya is aiming for me and
that's how greg thinks he thinks it's
all about him right greg but no on a
serious note
costa is looking to be an excellent
foreman whatever he is the 809c that
seems like he's under seated based on
his level of play
absolutely um we see i guess a uh
position which i'm sure both players are
familiar with
this is an interesting setup that i like
to go for as white where you go bishop
d3 and knight
g to e2 instead of knight f3 to deal
with 94 a little bit better so you
always have
f3 available and f3 e4 by white is
actually one of the
main plans in the position that's right
and i like what tanya did there when you
have less space you want to trade some
pieces
so that your pieces aren't stepping on
each other's toes she trades the darks
for bishops she plays a5 to make b4 a
little bit more difficult
and right at this point rook a to b1 was
played trying to get in b4
but watch out for some play on the king
side oftentimes black plays music h5
maybe knight g4 things like that to
have a surprise attack against the white
king yeah i'm used to white
playing h3 in these positions because
the move knight g4 is so annoying
h3 doesn't stop mate and g3 is
absolutely not the move you want to play
so taking advantage of that knight not
being on f3 watching over
uh h2 like he usually does going to e5
like it usually might
knight g4 i think even just throwing it
in is really strong here because
who wants to play g3 and moves like
knight f4 and knight g3
keep in mind a very you know common
tactic is like knight g4
knight g3 and then hey you want to kick
that knight out with h3 well knight
takes e3 runs into
issues already that's certainly true and
she plays 96 which
is a calmer move i still like the look
of knight to g4
but i understand why she was playing
knight to e6 she'll play bishop d7 her
position remains solid another idea for
black
is well she'd been knight to g5 she's
going for the aggressive plan but i was
going to say that black sometimes can
play b5 before
white does so because white wants to
open up the queen side and use the rooks
there so if you play b5 for black you
get this weakness on c6 but you're
getting a c4 square potentially for a
knight
yeah b5 is uh is a nice idea if it
doesn't get played i was gonna say
if tiny's not playing b5 i think she's
full committed to the king side here we
might see ideas like g6
h5 and she's already started with that h
pawn advance
and h4 by kostya to middle move robert
what do you make of h4 is that going to
be one he regrets later
i think he felt it was absolutely
required because if black plays h4
there's going to be a huge attack
so he says i'll play h4 but i don't like
the look of it there's
already i use a knight g4 for black if
you take my knight in g5 i push my pawn
to h4 and just try to checkmate the king
she prints her name like that h7 so
so she keeps her bishop on c8 open
although is there now
knight takes h5 as a tactic the knight
f6 is a bit overloaded there
yeah knight takes h5 i'm even looking at
bishop takes h7 but knight h5 is just
the better way to do that tactic you
take on h7 go back to f5
yeah it's one of these positions where
you are trying to attack so sometimes
actually having
fewer pawns is good because you get open
files but you're not getting a rook to
h8 anytime soon at least not that i see
but she can go after this h4 pawn it's
more advanced which makes it vulnerable
yep and this is already looking kind of
bad like knight takes f6 is playable but
even just knight back to f4
maybe even go g3 at the right moment
bishop f5 look for trades
this is looking better and better for
costa here knight c to e2 and just
just you know back that knight up and
that's the thing is she went knight g5
to h7 she could have just played knight
to e6 to start with so
she made this secured his route to the
square she could have gone to
immediately and she dropped the h5 pawn
so
it's still not game over there's plenty
of life left look at that move knight g4
watch out queen h2 is checkmate if you
play g3 look out for a sacrifice
on the e3 square coming your way and if
you take on g4 bishop g4
you regret having your pawn on h4 you
really wish that pawn
could push itself back to h2 or even h3
and now
look at this queen h6 rookie 6 rook g6
there could be
a blistering attack big fan rook e6 is
such a comfortable move defends the only
weakness in the position for tanya
coming over to g6 with bishop f3 and we
might see a beautiful sax mate type of
position
that's what i'm looking for and bishop
f3 could be considered even if your
rook's not in g6 yet because sometimes
you give up that piece to break open the
position the h4 pawn is hanging do you
need to defend that pawn
g3 no don't do that oh
oh my eyes robert you said don't do that
and it was like on a dime
immediately g3 was played and
what is going to happen here how does
costa could get out of this one rook g6
is coming
rook f6 i think g5 is as soon as g5
happens
it it should be close to lights out i
mean how do you stop g5 now
i don't know knight d3 to e5
wow but even there g5 takes h4 and yeah
the attack continues
so just take that and go to g5 okay it's
a fine move as well but
you were right though but taking it she
probably thought saw that h7 square is
not available so there's a background
checkmate but g5
in addition to attacking the knight and
trying to probably give the king the g7
square and she
there's g5 yeah there is g5 a very good
position knight g2
you have to play knight g2 and there
even could be a queen sack here like i
could see a position where you
sacrificed your queen for a knight on h4
yeah okay h5 and weaseling your way in
and tanya plays queen h5 that looks good
to me instinctively
yes and she's 12.6 seconds up 30 seconds
left
for white easier to play for black but
that clock situation is scary
what's white's move here rook c7 is c6
actually hanging
she's bishop before okay so queen d1
bishop back to f3 looks like it has to
happen
yes yep okay and that's you
don't make a draw don't make a draw i
think you can go back one more time i
can't remember
no but she had to play bishop f3 there
it was
the issue was going back to e4 she
should have gone queen
to g4 and queen h3 robert another
amazing chance for tanya
down the dream yes at least she's on the
scoreboard so
she can feel better about that game she
played pretty well there she
blundered upon and yet she still had a
pretty good position and that's the sign
of playing good chess is even when you
make some kind of crazy oversight
you still have some good chances right
now she fixed the problem
of the earlier game she played d5 rather
than having these triple pawns
this is standard play against the kings
indian you play a3 group b1 b4
black's gonna try to play f5 so you're
playing an opposite side of the board
this is kind of in her wheelhouse yep i
like it knight d3
f3 we might just see uh okay
g4 wow she's really anti-f5 there
i'm very anti-g4 that's a move that i
wouldn't have even considered
but if you could stop your opponent's
attack before it even begins then maybe
g4 is a good move and i'm just unaware
of this as a concept right yeah even
like knight d3 and i
i feel like you got to play f5 as black
but kosia he's showing some patience
here
just going bishop h6 trying to get rid
of the positional deficit that he has
that dark square bishop with this pawn
structure
wasn't looking too pretty on g7 he's
trying to fix that before he proceeds
but can't white just play a3 okay this
all makes sense
you're shutting down the king side and
then you're gonna be the side who
controls the pawn break on the queen
side
and now what's black can do f5 that
doesn't scare me you play f5 i can even
take it and open up the g file
but making moves like knight f7 back and
forth a3
b4 i'm not saying that white will win
necessarily because
black can play b6 and try to be solid
but black is very passive here and white
at least has aggressive intentions
yeah and and i think king g2 is very
reasonable here a3 rook b1 b4
those all need to happen um he's up a
full minute already kocia has used
six seconds right there's plus one on
this uh
on this match so he's getting you know
18 seconds
added because there's been 18 moves so
far but still he has used almost
no time and i like that move g5
he is locking up most of the action on
the king side
but controlling the pawn break h5 at the
right moment could be scary knight h8
knight
there it goes knight g6 and either into
h4 f4
the good news is you have a knight on d3
so the knight can't really get into f4
and look at her she's taking the
petrossian king walk going over to the
queen side i guess
yeah i think she really needs to play a3
i'm glad she has
just before black plays knight c7 a6 and
gets b5 in
for himself it's really important i
think for white to get b4
first this is a fascinating struggle she
can you know blacking over b5 now
but that knight went to d1 to go to e3
and perhaps into f5 so
you you have to figure out where your
attention belongs but really
chess is about full board awareness you
have to be looking at both sides and
here
h5 has happened and b5 that will happen
later and for white
you could play knight five check or you
can play b4 like
what is the way to go here but i think
this is a miss you're supposed to have
h3
in so that you can take back with the h
pawn um and she's sort of been forced
into this knight f5 thing but after
knight f4
i think most players would look at that
bishop versus knight scenario and say
look i don't know what the evaluation is
but should be kind of good for
for the knight yes because if you take
on f4 e
takes f4 knight b8 knight d7 95 thank
you very much for that dark square
outpost
in the center of the board you can still
break open the position of g5 to g4
later
so i would not take that knight but if
you don't take that knight
that's gonna work oh i like that h4
i think that's a super important move
and uh
full credit to tanya for finding that i
think it was like absolutely necessary
because
now if you like take that that
completely opens things up you can slide
the rooks over to the h g
files and maybe play on the king side
that's right because instead of locked
up position for this light square bishop
if you play knight d3 and then take on
h4 or something like that then why could
play f4 continue to open the position
for the bishop i like this decision by
costa you take me on g5 i take with my f
pawn the h5 pawn becomes a past pawn
and he's just trying to keep the
position quite close for now
and he's going to take over the dark
scores if pawn captures
ever happen still a tense position i
i think overall in a blitz game i would
always take black just because i feel
like white has to be so precise to
to somehow uh come out on top here i
think she's playing good moves but
as the time gets lower she's not going
to be able to continue that
at the same you know level of accuracy
and the knights just so easy to play
with easy to play in the dark squares
here for black
that's right and there's ideas for black
for c takes b4 and then a5 give me the
c5 score for my knight
white i would play rook h1 robita g1 and
just
kind of assume that my queen side is
okay but bishop d1 taking advantage of
black's last move when he played b6 the
light squares become more vulnerable
she's trying to play bishop a4
into c6 that could be really annoying
for black to deal with
absolutely absolutely and kostya has
is kind of in no man's land he has to
pick a side of the board to play on and
if bishop takes d7 happens
all of a sudden there's no knight
sinking into e5 and i think tanya's
rebound their bishop d1 and a4
is top notch and she should play b take
c5 soon and then a485 and just
rookie it's bad because then bc5 you
can't take with the b
pawn if the rooks are not connected with
one another and you don't want to take
with the d pawn because then a4
a5 is a thematic pawn break from white's
point of view and
actually voice position looks excellent
tanya is completely winning here this
knight can't go anywhere
a4a5 uh now just works
knight takes f4 a4a5 the time is the
only issue
but i love the way she's playing and she
can even punch through a d6 move because
if you take
on f4 with the g pawn rook g1 check and
you're trying to run away king f7
your king is not running too far
goodness dixon queen d5 check and that's
me
this is this is lost for sure even just
doubling slowly can't be that bad
watch out for queen d6 rook takes c6
cheese
and then yeah that would be the one
thing to keep an eye on so 26 would be a
good move it also blockades the pawn
and then maybe rook c7 but you're right
eventually white will play rook
b1 to g1 bring the queen over there that
knight is locked into
the cheese rook yeah there's rook g7
so it might not work here but i'm not
sure
yeah you have to go for it yeah he's
gonna try it king h6 and i think the
idea is you just move the king and play
queen g2 has to be made
nice yes king one queen g2 and the queen
g6
queen sack for me absolutely there's no
other way to do it robert
gotta be the queen sack and it's funny
because not only are you lying queen g2
you're threatening d takes c6 because
your queen's defended on d2 so that's
not just king f1 king e1 i love it
multi-purpose move
well what is this gonna be this is gonna
be a draw into a win
into tanya showing some comfort level
with this three minute portion yeah and
even though she was down on the clock in
this game
she played much better and you could see
that her plans
made sense they were connected with one
another she did make sense
in the first time control but something
about this time patrol she seemed much
more accurate
and allow the checkmate i would allow
the checker queen g6
very nice that's a good sport there we
go
i saw uh coaches face and he was like
well done he just smiled and
acknowledgement that's
that's really respectful he's got that
uh
got that smirk like yeah you know that
was that was good
you know hat tip hat tip and amman i
don't know about you but
i often allow my opponent to checkmate
me because it's no difference if i lose
the game by resigning or i get
checkmated
i lost the game but some people have
this huge aversion to
getting checked i think it's like the
most insulting thing to their ego
ever so it's i guess a matter of style
but i'm
very happy that kosia played that's on
me yeah like people like me for example
the amount of times that i've been like
checkmated in in a beautiful way is
probably zero
there's no chance zero chance i give you
that satisfaction
you know how how good tanya feels right
now this is come back season baby
i would never ever give my opponent the
fuel
to the fire that's gonna maybe uh burn
me okay
i feel that also you know like in
basketball slam dunk is a poster
you don't want the image of the
checkmate just on a frame in the wall
uh yeah behind you so i get you and
tanya by the way has gone back to the
line we saw in the very first game
and it had scored good results for kosia
but she took with the queen she did not
like the isolated pawn
so she takes the queen it's a turn in
development
bishop came to c4 with tempo now white
and castle but
black is more solid compared to the iqp
and now take this pawn
and interestingly enough queen takes
there's bishop f6
and i don't actually think that's good
for uh
for cost yet so i would have taken that
pawn early
and i almost think that e takes might
have been forced in a weird way
i don't know of course it would have
played that way that's right yeah it's
true and i guess here with that annoying
pin on the d4 point maybe knight e5 we
saw him do something like that in the
previous game
well actually he's going to be the one
with the isolated queen pawn
yep but the thing is he has really good
control over d5 it could be the idea to
go rook d1 d5
i would definitely consider 97 yes 97
standards have moved to try to plug the
d5 square if your opponent
has an isoqueen pawn you want to
blockade the square because
the idea is often to push that pawn
which opens up the board and the pieces
so d5 was played
does it work though i think just bishop
b2 right
yeah bishop b2 take and then you know
you just like pile up bishop
e6 97 and it seems like the best that
kosu could do
is maybe win it back but i'm feel like
i'm not convinced robert
i'm not either and i don't think tanya
is as well because i'm looking at her
she says okay i'll take that bishop e6
she completes her development and or 97
first
she can choose which way her bishop goes
i like this this is more flexible
because perhaps a mantra played bishop
g4 or something like that if you're not
careful
so yes she chose wisely at that point
yep i think bishop e6 is also
consideration but i think she might
stray away from that there's some like
knight
knight d4 and hg5s uh in the world that
don't look
the easiest whereas bishop g4 makes a
nasty type of threat you can always drop
back
to e6 right away that's right so bishop
g4
pinning the knight trying to take it off
the board and if you get enough trades
going
you don't feel bad about your position
at all she plays bishop g4 so 97 that's
just that precise move that she needed
and actually how does white deal with
this because kosi is down upon
and it doesn't look like he's winning it
back no i i'm literally about to play
just bishop e2
like there's no way i can deal with
doubled
and isolated pawns on f3 well
he says what he says you know he says
hey double isolated pawns at f3 yes
please
but this looks bad the queen's coming to
h4 the knights coming to f4
not good the one thing though is this
bishop is in the perfect
place for white hitting the f7 pawn so
you have to be a bit careful if you're
tanya but i like queen h4 and going for
an initiative maybe queen f6 is
a little safer but either way you kind
of like queen f6 i don't know why it
seems to watch f7
uh maybe not as committal then one of
the reasons why i wasn't so sure about
this
was was actually going to be a rook e4
or rook d4 move
because after knight f4 you pin yourself
and there's no like queen g5
because that's covered for the moment
that's true so
she played yeah and my question was like
not queen f5 because that blunders
knight h3 queen d4
but queen e5 and we cover
queen g5 to me and we're hitting the
knight
g5 is super committal so i'm not sure
about this i
am with you there queen e5 rook a to e8
those are one of those moves that like
you try you try to get tactical but the
problem there is after queen takes e8
and like knight h3 check and all this
good stuff to win the rook on d4 you're
you're getting bit mated
very quickly but it's the opposite if
you go queen e5 rook a8 queen e8 queen
g5 you get mated
so you have to start with bishop takes
f7 check
and rook f4 well see that that's a ko
i blunder checkmates cos you're probably
seeing those same ghosts and
oh wait i could be mated that's why he
played rook to e4
and now you can take the queen but then
the queen on h4 will be captured and the
bishop is stronger than the knight with
pieces on pawns on both flanks and the
pawn f7 being a target so
knight h3 queen takes f7 by the way keep
that in mind
yes queen f7 is a puzzle rush that costa
is just
he's just frothing at the mouth for that
and look at this his king is going to h3
and is there a check rate like king h4
h6 is that possible or
after h6 does white just play some kind
of rook g1 and sacrifice
you know and maybe oh my goodness by the
way after queen f2
is white playing for a win in any line
because king here
king here you always have checks on g2
h2 f2
right so oh my goodness she's she's
going all in i respect it i respect it
so do i because koji has 45 seconds left
and his king is on h4
so he needs to find i'm guessing there's
like one move because i see the
evaluation bar is like
a huge advantage for white but it's one
of these positions where it's either
like winning
or it's losing yeah rook g3 queen h2
king g4
there's no f5 keep in mind so maybe king
h8 is a response there just
not even joking king h8 h
h5 looks like too much maybe king f3 oh
i didn't even see queen 85
i wonder if she forgot the bishop still
pins the pawn because
if the bishop wasn't there now f5 check
works but the bishop is on
yes now this looks lost like rook f4
has to be winning for white and looking
forward there's a queen d1 check but you
can just
uh block it with your uh f rook and now
bishop f7 is mate
oh my goodness look at this king it's
got no pawns around it it's like
you know you uh people steal your
clothes after you jump in the lake for a
swim and you gotta use tree branches and
stuff just to cover yourself
very impressive very impressive uh game
by both players tanya went for it
tiny went whole hog there i i thought
that that was actually gonna result in
maybe a win for her
but flipped around by kostya there
robert and
the the match has been going at halftime
is nine and a half to one and a half
wow yeah and she could have just made a
draw there so i have to commend her for
playing for a win a draw and a loss at
this stage in time
that's not it doesn't make a difference
you're down by so many points you just
need to win games so
tanya she's played much better in this
three plus one section
and we'll see if she's able to continue
the trend yeah stick with us guys
because tanya is showing signs of life
in the three-minute portion and we'll be
back after this
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to anyone
who's maybe just tuning in
we are commentating the match of costa
kavetsky and tanya sachdev and robert
um we're at the halfway point of the
three plus one portion
and i think you'll probably join me and
maybe everyone watching and noticing
that tanya is playing
significantly better in this portion
managing her time
i think we're seeing a whole new tanya's
octave in the three-minute portion
we absolutely are and she definitely
wishes that we could restart the match
right now see let's forget about that
five minute portion because if we look
at what's happening in these last three
games she outplayed costa and some of
them in this latest game
she had his king on the edge of the
board he escaped credit to him for
finding accurate defense but she's
a much more confident player and her
chest has improved
yeah no doubt no doubt and uh what we're
gonna be getting into is the second half
of the three-minute portion so i think
there's about
you know 25 minutes or so on the match
clock so she's she needs to collect as
many points as
possible so that when we get to the
bullet
this get this match can actually be
attainable uh that she can actually win
this thing robert
yeah and unfortunately i don't think she
plays that much bullet so
it remains to be seen if she's able to
but first things first you have to do
this
one move at a time and she's blitzing
out this opening we've seen it before
and castle okay
some of the earlier games she played the
same is for the pawn on f3 i was just
trying to note the differences but she's
playing this very quickly we just saw
her play
a very interesting locked up game where
she was able to break through and
checkmate
coaches king so happy memories in this
one yeah she's gonna go for g4
so it's like hey that was uh that was my
only win of the match
uh you're not gonna get tricked me out
of playing that game again
sure i'm right back in there and i like
what kosia did
in that last game uh his position looked
quite passive
but eventually went g5 knight h8 knight
g6 and just try to
improve his positioning of that knight
there and i still
am not a huge fan of this i feel like
objectively white just has to be better
and yeah tanya will need to go for a3
and b4 and there it is
so immediate a3 this time and you have
to wonder in this break
uh this halftime break that we take uh
you know we're just sort of
relaxing taking a taking a breather but
these players they might be taking a
breather they also might be just
checking the lines and i'm always
wondering
what are they checking in in the break
here is tanya looking at this specific
line and saying look this is actually
the best
position i've had against the king's
indian let me double check this again
so make sure to know how to play this
again right and
while she's repeating it it's i think
this is the exact game that we saw
is that i think so yeah i don't know if
a3 was this early but i i think we've
transposed now to the exact game
yes and we saw cozy go to knight h8
knight g6 and knight
in and she played king f2 last and maybe
you should play
h4 early so like knight and now h2 or is
that possible
i totally agree i i like h4 as an idea i
think she might be looking at takes in
knight g6 as maybe like i don't get that
pawn back so easily
but i think h4 is great i also think
even just each three
and getting ready to meet h5 with
potentially capturing with the h pawn
is possible as well that makes sense
soon and there's another idea she went
knight d 193.95 last time
perhaps she'll start with knight d1
before playing b4 and hey
there's h4 so she's playing the
aggressive way fantastic move in my
opinion so
if it gets taken i think she just goes
rook to h1
and look i will i will take this h-punt
at some point in this game that says
there's no way around it
and you can do so by playing knight e1
knight g2
knight takes h4 as you said there's
nothing that black can do to protect it
and she plays knight d1 to e3 this also
makes sense
and if she gets knight five with check
good luck to that king on g7
yeah and how would you deal with counter
play like this it's always a kind of
important question
do you take my first instinct is b3
which is what time i played
the reason i don't like b3 is fully
opening the b file
will give black some counter play with
rook b8 and maybe that rook can just
go to b3 and all this stuff so knight e1
would have solved two different issues
they would have protected c4 with the
bishop but also allowed the knights to
come to g2 but still
i think b3 it makes sense she doesn't
want to have to think too
hard about the position her plan is now
very clear
yeah knight f5 is basically a win on the
spot
if it can happen so i think king h8
we'll see from costa
would be surprised to see a different
move uh also the speed
i didn't even have to look at the clock
because i know just you know that game
sense that flow
when you feel like one move is coming
just as fast as the other you get uh you
get that feeling and i can feel that
tanya is playing very quick
this game and that's why you see on the
clock she has another time advantage
great to see knight f5 super strong if
it gets taken you take back with a g
pawn and hey
those those rooks are both participating
all of a sudden and
now the rook on h1 is a very happy
camper knight takes h4 let's open that h
file
go for that king in the corner and black
just isn't in time
with any counter play it's not like you
could sacrifice a pawn and get your
knight in the game the knight c7 is
actually just
not doing much of anything it doesn't
have a true future to help so i would
probably just take on h4 but you have to
think about f5 at some moment like
knight h4 knight takes for f5 maybe
there's some tactic because the rook
isn't defended
very well on h4 but that should not be a
good point
i like queen h6 first there's another
idea just threaten mate
and then play knight takes h4 um at
least it definitely deals with the f5 so
maybe i see that f5 thing that you just
mentioned and it's like okay i don't
even want to calculate that
let's just play queen h6 but she goes
for this and like you said there's no
way it's bad queen h6 is going to happen
anyway
right you're doubling the rooks bringing
the queen in and h7
feels like it's just going to be a goner
but the thing about these positions
amman that frustrate me
is i know some of the obvious plans
maybe rook h1 maybe queen h6
but how do i actually checkmate black
and i need to bring another piece into
the game
but the problem i'm starting to see at
the corner of my eye is this rook coming
to b8
if i can time rook b8 well right now
there could be some issues where i can't
just bring all my pieces over to the
king side f4
that's a nice move i think because
you're marching your pawns forward maybe
that bishop e2
will get into the game as well as a g5
and stuff like that but that's
too risky right now yeah and what a move
f4 like i would think twice about that
positionally
but tanya looks like she's full
committed to this attack and
she's ready to just play f4 uh get that
knight involved takes knight takes f4
there's ideas like knight g6
knight to e6 as well bishop a6 though by
costa he's finally using that bishop
wasn't doing anything
from c8 finally we see the first real
threat from
from black's position and queen c3 i
like that move she says
i'm still going to have an attack and
maybe she will play bishop d1 bishop a4
i don't know if that amounts to anything
but at least it improves the bishop and
look at coaster
h8 now knight eight is there some kind
of breakthrough like a g5
and open up the diagonal probably not
yet with your king on f2
yeah my instinct after knight a8 was to
play king g3 or king e3 or even king
back somewhere
and then almost like you're ready to
almost sacrifice on e5 with the knight
on d3 so
i'm looking at like sacking on e5 as an
idea yes
and rook beats you play whatever bishop
takes c4 this is the counter play five
that's needed
g5 bishop takes c4 that probably scared
her so she went queen to c1 which
i think is a very good move actually
yeah
oh g5 is coming though yeah it really
looks
it really looks scary because what i'm
looking at is g5 g6
take on h7 and then rook h8 sacrifice
with queen h1 to h7 mate
nice this is actually just overwhelming
rook takes e2 king takes e2 the c4
pawn's defended that queen on c1 is in
the right place
and that king on h8 is not yeah g6
is a huge move next uh if that happened
i mean taking f6 looks
strong as well but g6 looks really
forcing as long as she notices that
queen h1
i really like that mating pattern you
showed and i think this is a good
practical try
by coastian and g6 she says i don't care
that's one check on c4 king goes right
back to f2 and
same situation 49 you're down exchange
and you're getting mated
checks on a2 king g3 king takes f4 if
necessary king's actually
mega safe there now here we go this is
the rook h8 mate that you've mentioned
yeah and so we're gonna see rook hey
cheat i hope she goes queen h1 i mean
you can't falter
after king g3 she knows there's no more
checks after either king g4
or king takes f4 yeah i like kg4 because
you don't even see a single check and
yeah it's mate yeah f5 king g5
you know if necessary can you take it do
whatever you want yeah
okay now queen h4 there's not a check
anyway okay rook f7 queen
sevens mate nicely done beautiful game
rook f8 here yes nice and that's just
the cherry on top a beautiful game
there's no other way to say it that was
a crush and are we going to have to see
for the first time
costia revisit that opening robert it's
so weird because
i got to give so much credit to tanya
right now i looked at that opening
that kosi played and well it's not the
best opening i kind of look at the dark
squares i'm like yeah that's that's
really solid
but tanya just makes it look bad she's
played
so much better in this three plus one
time patrol
and she's punishing that opening it
feels like kosia
knows that it's a bit risky but that
there are also some
things that need to be worked out but in
this time control
he's the one who's under more pressure
and tanya's been punishing it
yeah it's great stuff and what we need
to see
is maybe for the first time in this
match we need to see that energy that
she gets with the white pieces
and those beautiful checkmate wins is by
the way it's been two
amazing checkmate attacks with that
opening she needs to transfer that
to the black pieces if she gets a win
with the black pieces two in a row
i can see that momentum if it's not
already shifting like i could see it
fully shift
in the other direction she gets the
white pieces again another win
she could dominate as she already is she
could dominate this three-minute portion
right and she's down seven points right
now but i just looked at the clock just
15 minutes left in his time control
that could be good for like three more
games and so
yeah if you start winning you start
feeling better about your chances you're
still going to be the underdog but it's
way better than it has been and look at
her knight to b4
taking with the d5 square i'm going to
blockade
your iqp b6 bishop b7
now your pawn is a not necessarily a
weakness
exactly but in the style of cappa blanca
the longer it stays there
the worse it gets for the side with the
isolated pawn and the interesting thing
about isolated pawns is that
my understanding is the bishop from c1
wants to be on g5
or at that diagonal and then when the
bishop's on b2 with with
b3 played i i think that's just a bad
version of an isolated pawn you don't
want this bishop b4
punishes that really nicely it gets so
many trades in the position
i think that costa just has a bad
isolated pawn here he does and she finds
bishop before 94 is a devastating threat
trying to win some material
now you can play rook c8 trying to trade
everything on c3 play b5 winning a piece
but you're right that's a very
instructive point that amman is making
the bishop
wants to be on g5 and the reason why is
when you've isolated pawn
you have two open lines that's the
nature of an isolated pawn the c
and the e files are open for your rooks
and you want to be active and
wow wasn't expecting that was going on a
long rant there then i seen 94
and now if you think what is happening i
okay so my first instinct
is that it's it might work but it looks
unnecessary
loved her position here after rookie one
rook c8 looked like a great build up but
let's just see her idea knight takes c3
uncovering with that bishop still on b4
wow so okay so bishop c3
you take out z3 the rook hangs on e4
rook g4 played
and if knight takes d1 queen h6 coming
oh my goodness yes
i think you have to take on d1 and then
g6 happens
and you take it and the very least
that's a draw
but that's not something you want to
play into that's black
no and not in the slightest and because
if you don't play knight takes d1
your knight on c3 is hey you have yeah i
think you almost have to knight d5 i
guess is the other way and then queen h6
queen
f6 idea okay that's actually might be a
nice way to save the game and save your
king because
it's really scary to allow this queen h6
and you'll be down at full rook
but that king of jade lacks defenders
and this is an example where the bishop
on b2 suddenly looks
good from b2 hitting g7 it's like wait
what
that worked out too well she had the
ideal situation the blockade makes that
bishop on b2
just looked like a defensive piece now
if you get d5 for white you're right
that's
checkmating attacks of queen h6 like the
position is almost wild enough that d5
is like nearly a move you know what i
mean like you're so close to like
unlocking that bishop for something
crazy but i don't think there's any
question
queen h6 has to be the move right and
after queen h6 g6 maybe then d5
trying to mate on those dark squares
there wow oh i guess the knight's
hitting the bishop let's not forget
you're right you know it's like that
that guy
behind enemy lines and capture the flag
you forget about yes
and it also attacks the f2 square so if
you think oh i'm going to go checkmate
black in a couple of moves the queen f6
happens and that queen threatens the f2
pawn so then d1 is a hero
so knight takes g6 everyone's looking at
that right now
but is it enough white is down what a
full rook here
so the question is is this more than a
draw that's the question oh she took it
the wrong way
i think she took the wrong way oh my
goodness i see the evaluation bar
jumping
bishop takes e6 now looks bishop e6 is
the move
but how do you even take with the other
pawn that's so counterintuitive
fashion e6 is gross yeah
wow what a move you know amon
it's funny because in most situations
coach is like
capture towards the center right so h6
g6 it does make
some sense but not when you're being
attacked and now your king is caught oh
my goodness
rook takes g6 you can take that and wait
i was gonna say does the bishop
participate from b2 but no not quite
i think he's like bishop at five at the
end right yeah how
how crazy is that what a calculation
rook g6 takes king h8 queen
back to h6 king g8 and bishop
f5 threatening made on h7 and
you know there's like a battlefield of
corpses but there's just there's just
nothing to do about mate
this is checkmate by force and it's
going to be maybe this bishop h7 check
bishop back to g6
that's a really nice mating pattern that
we don't get to see too often so we'll
see like rookie eight as bishop h
i think i think we'll get to see it
demonstrated unless tiny resigns because
there's no other moves but i feel like
you kind of have to return the favor
right
and here we go bishop h7 check king h8
bishop g6
and the queen goes up to h7 where it can
take f7
when the king runs away so that's
actually why you throw in the check
oh favor not returned
favorite not richard declined just like
when you get a venmo request
like thanks for hosting last night um
you know you owe me this much money no
nope rejected you think i do
and we'll see if we get another
fascinating battle in this king's india
what an attacking game the games in the
three minute portion have really picked
up in like pace and intensity as well
yes they have and i think in large part
that's because of tanya she's playing
much more quickly
and they've been sharper for sure
and here we go this line again
is not red okay i was going to say is he
ready to admit that he needs to change
and yes we see f5 that's brand new i
like this though from costume not even
just for this match because it is
getting
out of hand but as a strategy saying i
am willing
in the middle of a time control to just
do these slight changes
and you were getting comfortable in this
line now it's like f5 wait do i take on
c6 or she just did or did i take on f5
do i leave the pawn e4
how do i react here and this is now true
king's indian style
takes on takes on f5 um she's basically
opened the entire center so so now
it's a question of is this center going
to be super strong and mobile
or is it going to be picked apart and
targeted by by tanya so
chess is just that eternal struggle the
the structure is the same for both
players
but you have different perspectives like
white's trying to say hey those pawns
are weak
black's trying to say no my center is
very strong and i'm going to show you
right and the question of when to push
pawns is a very difficult one you know
that
d6 to d5 is not available the e5 pawn
needs defense do i play e5 to e4 wait a
second that knight goes into d4
i give up these dark squares so speaking
of struggles that's one that you have to
dig deep to figure out because any pawn
move creates a
weakness in the square that was
previously covering
and can we just talk about rook a to d1
i mean that looks like the
the brainless move that i would play
here in about half a second
tax upon how are we going to defend that
we're
not but we're going to hope that hey
i'll give you d6 we'll take b2 but
you're right rook ad1 comes in very
naturally there
okay and knight c5 played looking for
maybe the e4 square
after taking on d6 and i wonder after
queen d6 if kosi will trade queens or
like queen
b6 a threat in that 94 idea that you
were just mentioning and keeping it
sharper because if he trades queens i
think he's just in trouble
and by the way can we play knight takes
e5 here i was just looking do i need to
take on d6 your pawn is pen that's a
good point
maybe i can just steal that pawn that is
a very good point
knight takes e5 looks dangerous as well
probably a lot more dangerous than queen
takes d6 because it's threatening knight
c6
and you're still threatening queen d6 on
top of all that
yeah and b3 okay so
she was tunneled just like we were at
first about this capture on d6
but when you play rook a to d1 you
should think i'm putting two pieces
on the same line so i'm attacking d6
directly but if that pawn were to lift
up i always talk about this too
if there's pieces on the same line if
the piece in between them moves out the
way what happens
that would allow you to spot knight
takes e5 and tanya now down a minute on
the clock
and the onus is still on coast here to
prove that he has
sufficient play here i agree i think i
think tanya is still doing fantastic so
b3 it may be an overly safe move but uh
can't fault it it's a blitz game and
she's played knight d4 quickly
there's got to be some some killer stuff
here those pawns look too weak robert
yeah just you can move that knight out
of the way maybe knight c2 go after that
d6 pawn riding away
like queen f4 to go after f5 and d6
it looks like black's position is on the
verge of falling apart
great suggestions yeah at this point i
think that
cosi played e4 so you probably noticed
that that tactic and this is the easiest
way to defend that
and now he's just hoping to go queen e7
maybe like rook
do you hate to cover queen f4 great move
yeah it's a
perhaps the cure is worse than the
disease because he went e4 to keep his
pawns he didn't want to drop a pawn
but he's not even down upon i see the
eval bar what does that say like plus
two close to plus two yeah right not
even down one pawn but
is two pawns worse so this is a
situation where
now knight takes at five uh the thing is
you walk into a pin but you've made e7
check your queen takes d6 coming
black seems and i love the confidence
that tiny played knight takes f5 a lot
of us might
uh see that rook on f8 and be like no
maybe this isn't right but you just get
that intuition that
no this has been trending in white's
direction for a while i'm just going to
take that
i know that it works that's chess
intuition for you and
look at this stuff yeah knight takes
defile you have to see that and
kosher okay i like what kosher did there
though that knight on c7 is a bit
trapped
rook takes d6 is there like a rook b7 no
because then knight to e8 so the knight
r knight e6 as well the knight's not
getting trapped
but i i like the effort from a bad
position yeah i think that's that's a
fun way to play
rook d6 i'm kind of surprised that
wasn't played maybe i missed something
bishop e5 knows rook c6
and i think she could have grabbed it
but she is down to 25 seconds so
maybe bishop bishop e5 rook c6 rook c8
rook c5 bishop h2 some nonsense
that's possible it's possible
well now she just stole that pawn and
okay looking great
yeah so extra two pawns the black king
is not saved
she should take this one but she's down
to 22 seconds we have seen clock
not be her friend today that is
absolutely true she's looking at
um maybe bishop e6 or sorry bishop d5
knight e6
uh just to you know get into an obstacle
position where she's up material i think
she'd be comfortable with that rook f7
as well
yeah this is pretty tough for cozy to
trade rook f1 check
rook f 98 or rook ups i like g3 i like
g3 so
you know get that king to g2 knight e6
next
yeah no rush right you're okay rookie
five i like that b4 when i think might
win a piece
and 15 seconds she's 15 seconds that's
coming down to check you got to go to h3
then bishop g1 maybe oh
yeah you don't bishop g1 connect white
king give me two
nobody wants to put their bishop on
jesus yeah i know i know
okay he's going pawn hunting b4 looks
normal here
yes where's this king going is it even
running away
don't make it i would throw b4 in throw
before it oh she's not trusting her time
no he's not trusting her time that
robert that was a big chance as well for
tanya i mean
at this point in the match you sort of
have to look at the score and know that
the three minute portion
is ending soon you got to collect points
where you can that's a great chance for
her
and this will be the final game most
likely of the three-minute portion
unless somebody loses very quickly and
we have a
trophowski again look what he's doing
kosia keeps switching his opening up
and i guess actually it was tonya
because is she always starting with one
knight of six or she sometimes starting
with one
d5 uh sometimes d5 i think
but whenever it's it's uh knight f6 she
still chooses she had one game bishop g5
g6
and then she also plays it with the e65
against the trump
yeah and i we liked the way that cozy
played that first time
f4 knight f3 i think that this is a
setup that
time does not enjoy in the slightest and
i think that
question made the right choice once
again isn't e5 a move here
for black something it looks like a move
that i would consider especially
knowing that f4 has like you know kicked
my bum for the the last couple
uh rounds i i just would play it because
i don't want to deal with that f4
anymore
yeah though the problem with playing e5
is that your center is loose
with the e6 pawn protected d5 everything
felt nice and tidy
now you could see the center collapse at
the moment
take and do we take oh shimmy 2 is
interesting that doesn't look right
yeah you've moved that bishop to d3 to
b5 and back to e2 so yeah i think that
bishop takes f6 was a better try
but instead coaster goes back and the
good thing is he's playing quickly
yeah this looks uh this looks pretty
solid for tanya but
um still a bit of like a weird position
let me say like
bishop c6 bishop e7 are my instincts to
just develop those pieces
yeah probably take that knight g6 though
um
looks solid yeah she goes for that she
wants to keep more pieces on the board
because
white is more restricted in terms of
space so if you have the spatial
advantage
and you keep more piece on the board
your opponent has less opportunity right
with their many pieces but
do not like that move no do not like the
knight on g6 now
is sort of ineffective and i'm just
looking at like
you know queen c2 a4 bishop b5
rook to the d file looks like easy play
for costa
and f5 you might just like never castle
or something oh bishop h5 is a great
no i was thinking the same thing i was
like you may not castle there's a way i
can force you to not castle by
pinning your knight and that could spell
some doom for you so you know what's
problem is when you play d5 takes e4
there was already a knight on d2
a pawn three squares from a knight
dominates that knight but now that pawn
is gone
the c4 square knight c4 right now rook
to d1
white is just really moving forward in
this position
and black is suffering yeah i mean if if
costa castled here
it would be a great move but rook d1 and
knight c4 is a much more direct way to
play queen a2 speaking about direct holy
smokes that is a gutsy gutsy call
wow that caught me off guard i didn't
even think about that pawn right i was
like oh i'm making the normal moves then
you
do that nonchalantly then queen takes a2
queen back to a5
i guess the e4 pawn is hanging but black
stole this pawn over there and maybe
that can help her chances but knight
takes e4
castle there might even be some
discoveries the queen takes g6 ideas
coming the bishop on c4 pins the f7 pawn
exactly
don't like the look of this there's that
g6 knight so just keep in mind bishop
pins the f7 pawn so the g6 knight is
loose
i still think castling's the best can't
execute any tactics just yet
but just watch that robert mentioned
earlier in this match it was a queen a7
in another game
he noticed it earlier when it didn't
work but keep it in the back of your
mind
because it processed that tactical
pattern and then when it does work it'll
be it'll be right there for you to
access
for sure and so if you're tanya you see
that
maybe you're playing like b5 to the
cloak there it is close that bishop off
bishop b3 c4 actually traps the bishop
and if the bishops get traded then you
don't have to worry about the tactic but
what you do have to worry about you push
your pawns your remaining pawns become a
bit more vulnerable
bishop d5 here just try to get a rook on
d5 c5 is
under attack b5 behind it i like kosu's
position regardless
great move great movement that's the
type of confidence he needs
to end this portion which has not really
gone his way i mean he hasn't done
terribly let's let's be clear but
um but kosia has definitely not done as
well in this section as
the five minutes so closing out with a
win the time is officially up
going into the break and into the bullet
with you know
12 to 3 lead is exactly the type of
confidence
and reassurance that i think he's
looking for yeah i think he's
just trying to get a better feel of
these matches in general he at this
point
and so tanya they both know that kosher
is going to win this match
but you don't want to take your foot off
the pedal because when you make it to
the next round and play greg shahadi
that's going to be another difficult
match and you want to be in it the whole
way through you don't want to take any
sort of you know breaks mentally like oh
it's fine i
you know whatever then you lose the game
you lose the second game and then your
lead is all of a sudden gone so
i think the coast takes every game
seriously he's that kind of chess player
and his position is good here and f4
he's going for more
yeah he he wants f5 f6 i mean it's
telegraphed and with time ticking down
for tanya
it's tougher and tougher to deal with
attacking positions easier to deal
with the position if kosio just went you
know rook d5 rook d1
this is going to be much more difficult
he's blasting that position open f6
i love f6 and take that bishop and how
do you
actually go and checkmate this king
bishop short knight to
oh oh e3 saying i like that actually
that was a good move
and it just shows you you don't have to
defend by protecting the pawn or the
square that's under attack
you can defend tactically and here comes
the rook to d2 yeah
oh just forgot just forgot the rook yeah
oh that's too bad
that's that's probably if i had to like
think of the worst way to end
the the three minute portion that i
think that might be the worst way
and wasn't the same with the five minute
portion that final game was one where
she found that queen a7 and all that
stuff oh yeah
yeah the final game has not been her
friend yeah that's true actually she
hung a rook in both final games
um so man that that is really too bad
um it's 12 to three so basically if this
one minute portion starts
and and tanya like doesn't win the first
game or it doesn't
show that she's just an insane bullet
player basically
um then you're already starting to to
count this one in the bag for
kosia but as robert pointed out um he's
uh
never takes the foot off the pedal right
and if i'm her coach or
you know her friend or whatever i'm just
saying make every move
pretty much pre-move every move because
that's the only way you have a
mathematical chance in this
and when you're playing bullet mistakes
happen and if you have an extra five
seconds
you just at least have a little more
time to calculate so it's a tough match
through and through costia is playing
very well but if i'm
in tonya's camp i'm just saying go just
don't even think
just go well good advice there from
robert we'll see if that's advice that
she heeds
we're about to take a break but when we
come back there'll be the one minute
plus
one second increment portion to conclude
this match
stay where you are
[Music]
and we are excited to get back into this
match hope you guys are still here with
us but first wanted to remind you
about the feeding online world corporate
chess championship that's a mouthful
february 19th to 21st and robert
there's gonna be the likes of google
taking part in this and just
all those big companies uh anyone you
think is hiding some
secret gms out there yeah there
definitely are some companies that
you're like wait a second i know that
name that's not just some casual player
in fact i played that person eight years
ago and they they whooped
but what's gonna be cool about that as
well is that teams are able to
get one player over 2500 so i'm sure
we'll see
uh the googles or whomever just pick up
some
some familiar name where all of a sudden
magnus carlsen is on a team and winning
the tournament
yeah i think uh i think a few of those
companies participating they just might
have the salary cap to afford one of
those top top players so
that should be kind of a fun less formal
event where
um you get to see you know what these
with these companies uh
have to offer in terms of chess so it's
an interesting uh initiative by
uh fidei so it is an official event
that'll be fun to watch but
robert we're getting ready for the
bullet portion and you mentioned some
advice that seemed good advice uh to my
eyes you mentioned some advice for tanya
hey basically pre-move as much as you
can because
uh if you're down twelve to three uh
let's be clear you have to win
every single game yeah and i think that
for some players it's difficult because
they'd
rather lose by a smaller margin you
don't want to lose by
20 points but a loss is a loss i said
this earlier so if i'm gonna lose
this match if i don't win my games i
might as well go down swinging
so tanya just play quickly go for it and
for kosia
hey let's see what he has in bullet
because this could be a good indicator
of how
he'll fare against greg shotty exactly i
think i think unless he
you know completely messes this up we're
expecting to see more of the scene that
consistency
um kosi has looked pretty good in all
time controls obviously the three-minute
portion
wasn't as good for him but he did win
that four to three
so although that was a great uh round
for a great segment for tanya
he still won that portion he just won
the first portion
so convincingly that it makes it seem
like it was a bad result for him
that's very true and there was that game
where tanya had the
fourth straw that she played on for a
win that was informed by the match score
so we'll see how tanya
does in the bullet i'm excited for these
games because i feel like we'll have
some tactical flare
uh in these next few yep and uh we're
off with the bullet tanya
immediately with d4 and i can see the
speed already from her right
i think this is great this is a good
start she's going back to this line
which worked before
all the positions that i've seen from
her after playing d5 in this line robert
have been great i'm glad she's playing
it again
right so the d6 e5 line which was
sharper this
hat gives her a clear plan and we just
saw her play in this variation
she had a nice game bishop g5 and in
that one show 22 rook 81 went after the
d6 pawn
and i'm guessing she did well we see
kosair with knight c5 instead of
bh that's the first different part of
the game so she did something that she
didn't do last time she played h3 and
then bishop g5 last time she played
bishop g5
cosi responded with knight back to f6 so
that whole h3 pawn just simply wasn't
there
and i think she maybe just forgot that
played so quick in bullet she didn't
even notice
or maybe she looked at it and realized
that kosi's knight back to f6 was a bad
move and so
she's just trying to come up with the
right plan but you're right that
inclusion
didn't seem noticeable to me and said we
have this pawn d6 hanging but the bishop
one g5 needs the queen's defense
and if d5 the e5 pawn is hanging this is
a mess amman
it is a mess it is a mess
rook ad1 is the move i want to play but
i'm looking at d5 is that coming
what a decision what a decision
i think she was worried about some sort
of f4 but then you can take on f6 if
that happens
right and right now i think she or the
h3 pawn is hanging from kingdom but b5
you need to take over the light squares
so
try to get your knight into the center
of the board but she was 94
similar idea i think that's reasonable
c5 is what i want to do
yes c5 d5 knight d6 even just you know
plant
plant that piece in there and i think
coach just playing very accurately right
now
he can play d5 play e4 with tempo
against that queen on f3
starts with rook to g8 that makes some
sense but d5 is not harder to play move
that knight out the way knight c3
hit the c6 pawn stop d5 because the e5
pawn is hanging
and there she finds it yep i like it and
in terms of threats on the king side
well h5 is looking to play bishop g4 and
create one so i love bishop d3 as a
response
yeah h5 is like brilliant because it
seems like what are you doing why would
you weaken your own king
but you're right bishop g4 was a nice
way to play and look at the light square
domination by tanya here b5
go b5 oh yeah okay if a5 then she can
play b5 that's fine as well um
b5 now we need b5 she's forced into it
right he's just saying i'm going to
break open the side of the board and she
plays that drops a pawn
does drop a pawn she's getting an end
game here but that's not going to be an
end game she wants rook before it by
black so that
if you want to trade the rook comes up
to d6 which is where it wants to be
yeah and rookies before it is it's a
nice move where you
don't get the night in the center on
time so black is up a pawn
still good chances to hold this game and
she'll get 22 seconds to coast is seven
six counting down you gotta move rick
takes e5
on h5 singing with check as well so i
don't think kosi is playing this well
but time is a factor
yeah and her king is in trouble but she
has time to calculate he has knight to
d1 king to h2
she's not losing on time that's usually
her in time trouble
bishop d6 maybe yeah okay h3
so does that knight come to g4 knight f2
and g4 sometimes hanging on d1 nice
hanging super hanging
oh no yeah yeah that's going to be too
much
she played too quickly rookie seven me
as well
that's two pawns g7 g7 i think she was
just gonna sack
or he was gonna sack and push rather
yeah bishop
f2 although it's not mate no
we just push the pawns yep
just c3 c2 oh rook out for this bishop
e5 for good measure
and now queen yeah that's too much and
that's going to be the first game
of the bullet portion i mean basically i
think if this match was
uh near level at this point the way the
speed that tanya is showing in this
portion
i think she would have a chance the main
thing is is just too far out of hand at
this point
yeah as soon as the five plus one came
to a close it was
sort of beyond hope i would say
and she's playing much much much better
in the quicker time patrols and
you're right that if she started with
the three-minute just the way and we
could
remove the longer time control of those
seven losses she would have played a bit
differently in some of these moments but
kostya would have as well right when you
have that big lead
sometimes you just say ah you know it's
okay i can go
but i have to give both them credit the
way they've been playing in particular
kostya
throughout this whole match he's been
quite dominant
yep and what we saw was a little
amendment to the move order
after knight d7 he didn't play bishop d3
first played f4
stopping that e5 move which he did not
like he definitely did not like that
opening
bishop d5 and this is already nasty for
for tanya yeah you're going to play d
takes c5 rook to bring a rook to d1
you can also let bishop c6 take upon e4
if you want but why not just increase
the pressure
on the pin piece she's got a castle here
i think it's the only move
yes and then bishop takes d7 i guess is
the response and
you have at least one castle queen side
yeah rook a7 knight c6
that's game over and there's yeah i
think she'll just resign here actually
yep so another another win for gossip i
think that
uh setup that he's gone for has been
highly effective uh in this match
especially
d4 e3 f4 with that c1 bishop already
developed that's just
that's just great uh great idea it's
worked like a charm for him and
i'm guessing based on the way that coach
just played when he does move on and
play the next match
we'll see different openings from him
he's a principal player he sticks to
what works for him
but now that his opponent for the next
round can see what he does i think that
he'll change it up
and bishop g5 there now this time she
didn't play h3 so now she's back to the
original idea of rook b8 rook d1 here
so i wonder what kosi is going to play
knight c5 again would probably be a good
amendment yes you're right and she'd
have to play h3 which was just a movie
you don't want to play it's a waste of a
move so
rook to d1 there's knight e4 ideas and
that's what you have to
look out for maybe knight f to e4 is
that possible giving up your queen to
take
a white screen on d2 definitely yeah i
think you you want to use that knight
um for sure queen e8 well it's bullet so
you got to take on d6 isn't that the
rule
you just got it free pawn take it even
if it costs you something
take there put queen to e7 if you need
to if the knight comes to e4 so
i think that she can just snag it
will she oh the the time being spent
here is already making me say she
probably won't but
i'm happy that she decided to anyway i
think it's the right idea take on e4
queen e7 right she does exactly that
knight takes g5 do not take the queen on
eight because knight takes f3
is check and even that's not so clear
actually because the bishop will take on
c6 at the end so maybe
i would have taken on e8 and say yeah
it's a blunder most the time but you
take it a half step further you realize
that bishop would take on c6
hit both rooks and a and eight
yeah who knows what happens after that
this is two bishops
um for for cosine because of this bullet
even if this wasn't bullet it'd still be
a game but because it's bullet it's
accentuated
knight takes e5 though bishop music what
a blunder yeah and it's
an easy blender to make because your
bishop's on the uh diagonal the queen
looks like it's
on the same file but still just take the
pawn run away with it bishop takes b2
rook g8 coming maybe this can be a quick
attack for costa
okay queen h6 looks fine rook b7 is an
idea just stopped by queen e7
okay and i'm still looking at rook b7 if
you play like rook g like can i
be seven can i play it yeah it's a funny
oh no but queen g7 at the end threatens
me
darn it looks so good now you can do it
though
you could have done it right there and
trade queens and rook takes e6 but
chances missed 91 guards g2 uh they're
down to 15
16 seconds apiece and this is not
looking very good for white anymore
black's attack
looks very legitimate and white is just
trying to come up with some threatens
mate so you have to play
h6 yeah and
wow what a move queen f5 with limited
time in the clock
yeah wow f3 play that's a tricky move
g3 solid and if you play knight takes f3
and x suddenly you're just completely
winning
right it's the committal decision to
play f3 the g5 closes down
trade queens take on f3 take on a7 oh
look at that rook
seven's meat wow what a move
oh my god what a move and now you trade
and take and now 95.
95.
you know she's gonna go knight she
sticks like knight she could go nitrogen
knight f8 check
just for uh
holy smokes this is why i was saying if
this match was like if the five minute
portion didn't happen this match is
incredibly close
yes this it feels like the
latter two portions have been a bit of a
toss-up so she's playing so
much better she's kind of found her
stride
way too late but since then we've been
impressed by the way she's played so
right now
she has a situation where look at this
she hasn't committed her pawn to d5 she
has adapted she's not just playing the
same thing over and over again
bishop b7 she doesn't have to put up on
d5 you mentioned earlier d6 there she
goes
now that knight doesn't get to the e5
square and and okay so
hear me out i see this opening i'm like
tanya where is this opening the whole
match
this looks fine cosy is not getting his
f4 95 stuff
where was this tiny can play this
position we know she can so i just think
in bullet you start to see people's true
in
intuition and tendencies and this her
tendency it looks great
yes and the simple matter of fact is she
was overthinking in the five portion
five-minute portions excuse me she was
spending too much time getting in time
travel every single game
and look what she's doing she her gut
tells her that i should play in this
manner her position is fine
so queen b8 threatens picks f3
she's making very logical moves
yeah bishop f3 is a funny move you got
to just bring that rook right back
and good move bishop d5 play c4 your
pawn structure is weaker
a little looser maybe bishop c6 and b5
b4
oh look at this tricky move e5 your
brook on a3 is under attack once we
start trading pawns so
very thematic and e4 becomes a threat
very thematic this bishop can just drop
back to f8
as you pointed out is hitting that rook
on a3 so bishop takes f6 played but
i think just even bishop takes f6 can be
the reply
i like it the pieces are uh just
breaking free
in this position and knight takes f6 the
pawn e5 is offended because the rook on
a3 is under attack
so justin is trying to play e4
tactically that move looks possible and
as you said bishop fade
as well whoa committal
so there's bishop b7 c6 bishop takes f3
i don't know about that
i both hate it and like you at the same
time because she's trying to take over
some of these questions d5 now hits the
rook on a3 but that's
very tactical e4 first well that's for
d5
but she's missing between h7 yeah he
missed it as well
oh so it works now and you can't take
with the rook on a3 because rookie one
is mate so
and the brook's covering f7 so hey it
worked
what a crazy turn of events there queen
e7 okay taking over the open file
i like white's position though i don't
see any huge risk that bishop on d5 is
worth the rook especially with two pawns
you have yep although
oh okay rook rook a3 trick bishop takes
f7 although does that work hang on
bishop
oh f7 king f8 nice
you're right yeah so what's this this
game has been a
series of tactics like quote unquote
working and then wait they actually
do work in rook f6 look what she's doing
she swung her rook
from a passive position into an active
one look at that i love it
yeah rook d2 love it rook d2 and rook d3
rook back to d2 you could probably just
oh no oh no
i was suggesting it and it runs right
into that
how did coaches see that so quickly
well costa would have beaten like tanya
you i mean like he's just taking names
right now it's not enough that he's
winning this match
oh my gosh and her plan would just go
rook d3 rook back to d2 and pin the pawn
and attack him yeah exactly
oh that's so disappointing for tonya
there
and we've seen this opening time and
time again um it seems to be going well
for tonya so i
don't blame her for going back into it
no i don't either and
she goes quindy too the rook's coming to
d1 we'll see i would use the other rook
though she played rook
after d1 i like rook a to d1 i don't
know if there's a big difference
i do too i'm trying to figure out you
know what is the difference she keeps
going to work
fd1 okay what is that rook
on the a1 where like what does it need
to be like why why is that rook
move the one she goes for but this
worked out last time for her
okay so same deal queen e7
knight g5 queen takes the eight possible
but i think she's going to repeat
of course yeah and bishop e6 not played
that was
a blunder pawn yeah but can't white just
play like rook d6
rook d1 i like d6 take over the board
oh okay knight g5 is clearly on her mind
yeah oh my gosh knight g5 and there was
like rook d8 tactics
wow wow yeah that would be quite special
if that happened
rook d8 yeah we're not we're not getting
that right now
oh no hey maybe round two yeah
quite possible that would be ridiculous
now we're seeing a repetition yeah can
white somehow play on here mcqueen goes
to d6 now
no easy to draw but now that they've
found that draw
cosy can repeat that draw every time
they play that game now
so tanya has to find something else
yes and we're back to the queen's gambit
declined
so right she played c5
and here it goes again this is back to
game one
okay so this and i like that decision
we've we've seen this before and i said
the first time yeah
like ed5 and knight c6 and now in bullet
we get to see her play
and she's got a crushing position where
was this before
d4 now for black might be playable
because the king's in the center so you
quickly break them
that's also a good move mm-hmm
yeah take back and that knight doesn't
have great squares to go to knight e5
knight d3 is crushing wow actually
can you even stop that that looks
winning
chess can be that simple sometimes huh
maybe you have to play a3 after knight
d3 some sort of lucky
save like knight d2 and 85 king e2 or a3
right away
so this is gonna happen and after knight
d3 like a3
she'll play bishop e7 and like bishop f6
all right f5 and then bishop f6 so she
can just
kind of take her time i think that that
that should be
what gets played but we'll see bishop b7
and f5 is a great way to play
i think knight b2 is the wrong okay
that's also energy
bishop yeah take on
b2 maybe yeah maybe now is a better time
to do it just because
uh the pawns on the a file easy to get
but she goes bishop c7
and she wants bishop e5 oh
oh i would have played rook b1 oh there
was knight f2
i guess that's why you played it i get
it now yeah there was a knight f2 threat
how many different tactics are there
here it feels like bishop g4 check it's
good f5 is good bishop e5
i would go f5 i just can't stomach
losing that pawn
it's everything you take the pawn f5
happens
and then your knight on c3 drops yeah it
has to shoot
okay i would have said pawn f5 but oh
should check made this king somehow
stutter step where's the mate though no
just bishop c3 rook c8
probably just simple chess development
nice bishop d2 is going to be played
knight takes
they f4 like one yeah she could choose
her which one to take
but this is a better one because knight
c2 is next after bishop e1
yes that's a good call so she made the
right decision and now you take that
bishop
and you're crashing through here rook t3
win wins a piece because if you go 982
you trade rooks and rook d1 check the
end wins the rook in the corner
nice wow what a game beautiful game
but that again that's just like a much
better way to play against cosy's
opening almost looks like she's refuted
kostya's line that he's been playing the
entire match yeah
it's overthinking
right you have five minutes on the clock
oh if this could happen
it's what happens to me in classical
chess regularly where i just spent
way too much time thinking about things
that i could have played in
five minutes rather than 20 minutes so
okay oh you gave the bishop oh
anymore she needs to get her rook behind
the a pawn
that's what she really needs to
accomplish here oh she got it in front
of her k5
nice yeah that's what you want
for h6 oh there's f6 yeah i had the same
exact thought
oh f5 is winning it must be
wait f5 rook takes a5 as possible i
didn't even notice
yeah me neither i'm like so focused on
like what's happening here but
i think she's winning because she
protected her a pawn now rook g8
and then g pawn also runs so okay she
should win this game just a4 king a5
slowly up the board
a3 and there's no rook f3 check this is
actually how you draw these positions
when you're down upon because you like
keep checking the king away but you
don't have look after we check because
the pawn on g4
and now it's too late
nice game like tiny is putting some
beautiful games together in the three
minute the one minute portion
this is just it feels like a regular
match again it's it's almost like
there's this
this five plus one handicap somehow
that's in place that
means this match is just over from from
that portion alone
yeah she's sticking right with
costa in the bullet and that's kind of
surprised me i would have assumed that
the bullet portion is where costa would
thrive and tonya would suffer
but now that she's just playing kind of
with a
clear conscience she knows the match is
over there's less pressure in that
regard
she is playing better chess yep okay but
here here i was saying they're gonna
just repeat this draw unless tanya does
something different so
are they just going to keep drawing this
position maybe
or what else can she play so bishop f6
is what caused the draw rook d6 is the
way to stop it yeah
nice they're slowly developing theory in
this line e4 this is looking scary the
b2 pawn bishop or queen to e5 comes to
mind
i give you knight d4 i'm bored the rook
on d6 is
in trouble so he plays knight back to e1
yeah knight d4 queen e5 looks
brutal queen you have rook a to d1 queen
takes b2
i don't really like that white is
retreating in this manner
but perhaps this activity that work on
d6 can win the c6 spawn and
maybe eventually the white's piece will
get out but if your bishop f1 is the
your best move that
it's not so promising yeah agreed
agreed maybe g3 knight g2 knight f4 just
as a
idea to get that guy doing something
wait rook d oh the bishop was the g8
square returned to i was like
is there a back rank mate rook d8 but no
there's always bishop to
g8 yes tricky move queen e7 i like that
move though
mm-hmm queen b7 get in there be annoying
for sure then rook b8 to b2
oh okay so rook b8 and then rook b1 and
then bishop c3 that looks lights out
yeah i don't see how to stop that well
that's not gonna help
no but i understand why she did she want
to play rookie bishop c4 she's just
a little too slow in that position one
move too slow
[Music]
16 and a half to five and a half um
there's under five minutes left so
hopefully we get um basically as many
games as possible because at this point
these are just
entertainment the games have been pretty
exciting in the one minute portion
yeah and this house
well they did trump asking they traded
on f6 and yeah the pawn
was there for the taking and it's just
you don't expect your pawn to blunder it
and you're kind of pre-moved even if you
haven't physically pre-moved
you've mentally pre-moved so i
understand what both players are kind of
doing here
and castling queen side
you know fortune favors the bold but
that's real bold
okay i'm playing d5 c4 b5 b4 i'm just
going for a mate yeah it's bullet just
just get in there c4 next b5
i like it okay this is
that fell a little slow c4 b5 your queen
should go to b6 but she's just castling
queen side
yeah now i don't think we will see c4
that as much
nah it doesn't look as strong it's funny
bishop a6 says
now c4 like blac4 and b5 yeah c4 b5
a4 please we want to see that attack yes
okay building it up there it is there it
is
there it is and here we go here comes
the pawns before now you now you just
realized that black's
better like significantly better much
better because normally when you lock up
the queen side
white's plans go f4 f5 and he's running
away
he is running that king away queen a5 is
definitely the wrong vibe
yeah you need the pawn on a5 right yes
and you need to move your king
and here it goes king d1 queen e3 king
king is running to the center
oh yeah white's gonna get a very
playable position here bishop d1
he wants knight c2 to cover but i still
think you just shove
b4 in yeah that looks too slow
knight f3 now oh queen f3 whoa can i
take on c3 you have to take what the
queen
back then wow to protect the b2 square
that looks really good
maybe just rook a8 yeah exactly right
take over the open file look at
she's playing like whoa okay maybe
it's gross yeah this is oh an f6
thematic french break
i think in that position you just go b3
and like rook a8 and you just
like mate basically like the king is
completely in tone
oh my god crushing game by tanya this is
beautiful
queen g3 there's rook f4
wait knight takes before though the
attack goes away
and i see the evaluation bar is freaking
out oh you
after queen g3 they want you to move
your king and then play b take c3
after queen takes f2 i guess yeah that's
a fourth oh and look how quickly this
turned around
yeah it's over now immediately over for
for tanya it's uh
1-0 she grabbed one pawn which allowed
the tactic with the check and then wait
bishop is mate oh no it's not
wait no king city before his b3
what he walked into discover check g4
oh my gosh i should pay for it he
thought it was mate
and that's why he did that and now it is
made for real
wait oh bishop e2 just rook takes e2 and
then rook d2
and then king c1 and then i move my rook
anywhere and then it's just me
it's winning for sure it's just
completely winning rick takes b2 is a
great move by the way yeah yeah just
next mover premium rook takes b1 these
games are great robert i'm just i'm just
sad that the match isn't
you know swinging in the balance yeah
that would make it much more exciting
for us and much more stressful for the
players
and well we want them to be stressed
yeah yeah we definitely do
that was a fun game though that was
wild like the white king i thought was
mated like seven different ways
and then there's that one little check
which forced black to react
i didn't force her to react she chose to
but it that was the natural move
knight took on b4 and all of a sudden
white turned things around and yet she
still
won the game so we're back to this
and this is where she went h3 and she
went like bishop g5
well she's supposed to play dc bishop g5
without h3 so this is actually the first
time we've seen this position
okay so how should white play this i
would
want to play f2 to f4 but i have to move
my knight first and that doesn't look
so well okay she's on the same page as
you i think
yeah before and the thing is if you play
e4
white tries to just keep those pawns
stuck in place and eventually
uh fight back but king h8 yeah
and if e4 you often want to play like
knight f1 and e3 you get a nice block
eight there but i think that
i think that cosius position is uh is
shaping up here
knight h4 is queen h7 okay you can just
right escape that way
and if pawn takes e5 pawn takes g5 like
this is
a lot yeah that looks fun although i
would play hg5 in a heartbeat as black
here
yeah the bishop takes f6 at the end and
you have the bishop here
this looks solid dark squares
bishop d3 is probably the move i would
have played just
oh wow what's happening here bishop d3
maybe the move
uh you were talking about oh but if that
knight moves queen h5 and bishop d4 is a
completely
mate so queen trove is good now i think
queen h5 is good
oh man yeah that knight can't move
bishop d4 is ko so if you move
what knight e4 gf3 knight f6 and
hope that you can get an attack out of
nowhere yep i think 94 is the only move
gotta get rid of that bishop oh okay
last game over yeah bishop
d4 yep and i wonder if rook f2
if the move is like g3 g3s
to be as precise as possible yes this is
just
well this the match is over the time is
up yeah and the time is
up i just noticed that now wow that that
whole bullet portion was just a flurry
robert i barely noticed it go by and as
i
mentioned during the match i just wish
that the the match was tipping in the
balance as we're watching those games
that's the only thing that would have
made it better because the games itself
were very exciting yeah and i like that
you used the word flurry it's snowing
quite heavily in new york city
and this was a flurry of tactics and i
loved
the shorter time literal portions i mean
if tonya had gotten off to a better
start
this would have been even more exciting
match but despite the score
i thought that we were treated to such a
wild set of games a tactical affair
and both players deserve a lot of credit
and we'll be joined by them soon with a
post-match interview right
yeah yeah we'll get the the players in
here as usual for an interview so
hopefully everyone who stuck around for
the match uh sticks around for the post
game it's always nice to hear the
players take the time to give us their
thoughts
on the match so we'll hear both
perspectives after this
we will be right back stay tuned for the
interviews
[Music]
so
and welcome back everyone we are happy
to be joined by the players from today's
match uh both tanya and kocia
joining myself and robert here um i'll
start with you cos here first of all
congrats uh a nice match victory and
it looked like the five-minute portion
of us was like a huge reason
because the other two portions were
incredibly competitive do you know why
the the five-minute portion was so
successful for you this match
um i mean thinking about the games i
felt like
i mean they were they were competitive
except just there was a few games where
i
i think i just had like a massive time
advantage and i just felt like i don't
have to do anything now i can just wait
and wait and just wait for an
opportunity
um so i feel like that was kind of the
biggest thing really
and yeah tanya what do you think
contributed to that because at first
you were deliberating you're spending a
lot of time do you think you were loved
a bit by the fact that it's a
five minute blitz game and usually you
play three minute or what was going on
there
no i think uh costar just dominated the
match and the five minute portion
especially i think he was
better on the clock he was better
prepared and
even the few games that i managed to get
good positions i never had enough time
to
uh to really make something out of it so
i lost out on that as well
and then in these formats it's really
difficult to actually come out if you
start so badly as well
but then at some point it was like okay
if i'm playing bad at least try and play
fast so i tried to do that
when we were uh in the other formats
yeah it seemed like that was a good
strategy um
back to you costia the the openings that
you were choosing i mean
you guys you and tanya had some
theoretical discussions it seemed like
there were a few openings
there was like you know five ten games
maybe in the same line
uh did you look at any of the openings
in the break because you knew that you
were getting them over and over
uh no i didn't actually because i felt
like i felt like i was doing well in the
five minute portion so i was like okay i
don't have to change anything and
and then once i got to like the three in
the one minute i'm like it's too fast
for
prep so whatever i'll just figure it out
um i really just try to
choose positions that i feel like you
know you don't have to know
a lot of like specific moves but just
kind of playing for
ideas because last year i really i
really got crushed by lawrence because i
was just trying to play like all my main
openings and like
then spending a minute you know trying
to figure out okay what's the critical
move here like what do my notes say
uh but i think for blitz that just not
very practical
yeah that makes sense and oh tony i have
a question for you because i'm in this
boat quite often
what would you say are some of the main
differences between commentating
and playing these intense matches
i mean it's it's completely different
it's uh
it's a different profession actually to
be playing and not just not just
commentary and
playing matches i think even playing
blitz and
over the board and playing it online
just feels like two completely different
uh different formats i don't play as
much online and i think i struggle a lot
with it it was
pretty similar actually last time i
remember i played levy as well and it
was very difficult
uh in that match as well i think when
you're doing commentary it's a lot um
the the pressure and the stress is
obviously a lot less you're trying to
break down
in more theoretical and more ideas
but i think when when you're down
ticking on the clock it's really not
about that it's it's just about making
moves and then you really understand
that
the players who are playing these games
that you're commenting on
it's so different from what you're
talking during commentary and what
they're thinking so
i i think it's incomparable yeah that's
that's really good insight
from tanya who has done a lot of very
professional very high level
commentary uh tanya the other thing
that's kind of interesting is
we know the match is happening quite
late for you but ironically it seemed
like you were
playing a lot better near the end of the
match where it got even later
did you feel like you were in some weird
way waking up like as the match was
going on
i think so i think the more you get into
the rhythm of it i think the the faster
you play and like i mentioned the five
minute potion went
so bad that it just felt that all right
if i'm not at least
uh if i'm not going to score points at
least i shouldn't lose on the clock
and then you just try and uh play faster
i wish that would have happened sooner
also i think the five minute blitz as
robert pointed out was
is quite a different format than the
three plus two that we are so used to
playing
uh it's kind of difficult i wasn't
really able to sort of handle and
balance the time situation and costa was
just
very strong in that uh and yeah
eventually it was just about uh
understanding that you know just to just
to play fast regardless of it's better
to lose on the board than to lose on the
clock
indian costume i have a question for you
uh the first game of the match was one
of the most impressive i think i've seen
in
any of these matches so shout out to you
for that
and i guess i also want to shout out
your channel so you do a lot of coaching
and streaming with chess dojo live so
how would you say that has impacted you
as a player because
when you're coaching you are studying
and you have to be well prepared in
a variety of different openings so could
you elaborate on what that's been like
and you know how you work yeah i would
say actually all of like the coaching
streaming work
that runs counter to playing i feel like
if you want to be a successful player it
feels like
that has to be just your main priority
when you wake up and everything else
kind of rotates um around that so
leading up to the match i was just
trying to play a lot online like i
played some matches
um shout out to the dojo by the way
hopefully people were supporting it i
really appreciate
all the fans but yeah i play like some
matches i just tried to play a lot of
like online
chess and um i really feel like these
things are very much about
form and if you haven't played in a
while like i know tanya was doing like
tata steel which is
i mean a huge i would gladly do that
instead but
if you're not like playing very
frequently it's hard to to have that
that rhythm and um especially the the
pacing i think
yeah right and uh kosia i mean again a
congrats from us on your
performance greg was in the chat during
the match because he
is you're now your next opponent as you
move on in this tournament bracket
and he was honestly i'd say he seemed a
little frightened watching that five
minute portion
he said oh no cost is coming from me
what do you think about greg shahadi as
a potential next opponent oh man i mean
it's gonna be
a great match i i really haven't played
greg that much at all maybe one or two
games
um i think he's he's definitely like the
favorite but
like i'm just gonna spend the next i
don't know 72 hours preparing for him
and
we'll have a good time yeah i was gonna
joke and put the uh the dojo versus the
u.s chess school on the line you know
winner gets both but i think we'll uh
leave you each to your
professions there but both of you are
seriously such a great match tanya of
course sorry
that the early stages didn't go your way
but you fought valiantly and you had so
many supporters in the chat who were
rooting you on
yeah thanks yeah congrats thanks for
joining us both
thanks guys all right good luck
crosstalk for the next one
oh thanks tanya and there you have it uh
total sportsmanship from from both sides
and we thank both the players for
joining us for the interviews and of
course um playing the match you know
tanya is busy um commentating and and
she elaborated quite nicely on how
different that was
robert from playing and i i totally
agree and echo
uh those sentiments yeah it was also
interesting hearing from cosi about the
coaching and
how you know he was just focused and he
was really preparing
and i could sense that just based on his
match against lawrence last year he said
he prepared
too hard he was going for these main
lines but those were immensely
complicated so he actually
boiled the positions down so one that he
was familiar with he was able to play
quickly and as we see in the bracket
he gets greg jihadi and greg is as good
as they get in this field
he is the top overall seed we know that
he is sort of a blitz legend if you will
and he
has looked sharp throughout including
last year
so what do you make of that matchup oman
what do we do you think there'll be an
upset and actually we should preview the
next match as well in the bottom
left-hand corner
exactly uh first of all talking about
kostya moving ahead in the bracket and
the
upper left of the screen there in round
two he's playing greg i think the coast
that we saw today
was lethal i i think he can absolutely
take out greg shahadi i think he could
take out
anybody um in this field because the way
that he was playing that five-minute
portion was
dominant now don't let that make you
forget maybe you know how dominant greg
is in this format as well so greg's an
experienced player he's used to this
i think that is just going to be a
heavyweight matchup towards two really
strong players i can't even call it
robert that's fair and tomorrow we get
eric rosen
and cigar shaw and that's going to be an
interesting one because
tanya doesn't play that much online i
have never seen
international master shah play so i know
eric rosen he's streaming
i've known personally for a long time as
well but that remains to be seen
will he be informed and i know he has
many many fans
he's a popular commentator he's been
doing this a long time and people
sometimes forget that commentators can
also
dabble and play themselves too yeah you
know that's
that's uh i like to repeat that phrase
in the mirror from time to time but
remind myself there's there's still hope
robert
but uh that'll be a really exciting
match because obviously the winner of
that match moves on to
face levy rosman so that'll be an
exciting bracket no doubt
uh i am not a gm we're almost uh
finished round one
which is the exciting part so we're
about to move in to the next
round of the tournament and we get
closer and closer to you know moving in
from the quarterfinals
to the semifinals and then obviously
into the final for the entire thing so
we're moving along in this tournament
and uh as you mentioned the the final
first round match is going to take place
tomorrow so we're excited for that
robert but
concluding for today tanya unfortunately
did not have a good
five-minute section and i think you and
i and even
kostya sort of agreed that if that
section went a different way this entire
match was up for grabs
that's true it just she got going too
late
she couldn't make her way back into the
match but she did play very good chess
overall
and well amman for us you know we
commentated we had a good time
tanya just switched over from
commentator player are you gonna do the
same arena kings later tonight will i
see you there
well i think eric is already taking the
reigns from uh
from arena kings because he's actually
been doing really well
in some of them so for eric he's
identified the style for arena kings he
either finishes like
top three streamers or like you know
bottom 300 players
so that's the style you have to have so
um if you're playing in that
remember chess fans guys in the audience
arena kings is happening
later today but uh that's gonna be
that's gonna be it for robert and i in
the commentary booth it was a
great time today buddy it's a pleasure
it's all mine
take care guys thanks for watching and
remember arena kings later today so
stay tuned to the chess.com channel that
will be hosted right here
you